我先highlight一下
我们最近收到同学们的作业
然后真的是很很震撼啊
就是我们的同学们真的人才济济
你像这个卡通化的渲染
是不是觉得非常的酷
那么再给大家看一个啊
这个是很风格化的一个效果
然后再看一个最后一个是最酷的
我认为直接上了motion blur这个效果了
然后我是觉得就是我知道同学们做这个作业
做的头疼
肚子疼确实挺难的
就是就像我讲的
就是说呃其实理解一个算法不难
难的是在于一个很庞大的系统里面
怎么去把这个算法做进去
但是的话呢我觉得有这么多
那个就是我们的好同学
我们的学霸做的这么好
也给大家一点鼓励
但确实就是我们的那个课程组的话也很辛苦
就是在一个一个的看同学们的作业
每天都有惊喜
然后另外一个的话呢
就是那个给大家做简单做一些前排课程的反馈
因为其实因为这段时间准备课程
准备的特别的辛苦
然后呢我们自己很自责
就是我们课程组觉得跟同学们的互动
还是做的不够
然后呢
所以呢就让我在课程中呢
给大家做一些我们的课程组的反馈
比如说大家反应
就是说PIA的引擎的源代码
看起来还是有点难啊
这个确实是这样的
就是说我们自己也在那个看这个代码
我们觉得代码架的还是不够好
就是不够简单
不够清晰
所以我们正在做一件事情
就是说对整个引擎代码进行一次重构
然后的话让整个这个架构更加清晰
更加的好理解
然后我们后面的话呢会持续性的
因为在上上周
上周我们在出了一些wiki嘛
然后呢我们这些在后面就是这个重构完之后
会出一批新的这个wiki的文档
帮助大家去理解这个引擎
所以说大家如果看不懂的话
不要不好意思
肯定不是你一个人
那就直接告诉我们的课程组
那我们这边来改进
就你看不懂一定是我们的错
那么第二个的话
就是那个大家说那个挖坑的那一层API特别难懂
这个地方的话呢
我觉得实际上真的是我们当时犯了一个错误
因为那个时候我们在考虑说
我们教大家做引擎的话呢
就是说选择一个更加现代的
更加前沿的这样的一个平台
这个平台一致性也会好一点
但是呢实际上因为win这样
上次我的课上讲的就是
他非常的趋向于硬件底层
所以说对于初学者来讲的话
确实蛮抽象的
不像学OPENGL啊
就很简单
很易上手
所以的话呢这件事情我们想了想
好像重新改吧
好像有比较难
我们打算的就是把那个上面那层
就是我我们以前讲过的那个叫RIHIG层
就是绘制渲染的这个虚拟化
这一层的话呢
我们把它抽象的更干净
更好懂一点
这样的话呢再配上一些我们的文档
然后呢让大家能更方便的理解这个
这个就是说我们的渲染是怎么发生的
而且尽量不需要碰到wen的非常底层的API
那么另外一个的话呢
就是说大家也说我们需要一些更多的学习资料
因为很多算法在课上
我们只是蜻蜓点水的点过去了
大家后面还是需要看这件事情的话呢
就是我们呃确实大家说的很对
所以我们后面可能会准备
就是在我们的引擎的小网啊
小引擎的网站上
放上一些我们的一些参考资料的链链接
可能因为有些文章它是有版权问题的
我没有办法把那个原文直接给大家
但是我会把链接给大家
方便同学们自己去下载和阅读
这件事情
我觉得可能需要大概一两周的时间
因为最近我们还得认真的准备课程
所以有可能是在
就是后面两节物理课程结束之后
我们有一个星期的break的时候
我们把这个事情给同学们准备好
然后呢包括另外一个就是同学们普遍反应
就是真的第一次做作业了
我记得很很很有意思
在之前大家老是问我说我们的作业
我们的作业呢当我们的第一次作业布出来之后
大家就说哎呀
我们的时间不够
所以呢就是现在看到同学们都很想做这个
做完这个座位
但是呢时间又不够
所以的话呢我们决定把这个第一份作业的时间
截止日期的话延长到这个月的30号
这样的话
大家就可以有更多的时间去写这个作业
然后有什么问题的话
也可以跟我们课程组去
这个就是说去反馈
那最后一个的话
那就是我们要隆重隆重的感谢一下同学们
给我们的小引擎取名字
我们真的是非常感动啊
大家取的名字都非常的有才华
我们现在已经收到了将近两三百个名字了吧
而且每个名字质量都很高
同学们不是说只是给了一个名字
嗨写了很长一段话告诉我们说
我对这个小引擎的想法和预示了
其实看到这一趴的时候
我们课程组还是蛮感动的
因为实话实说
准备这个课程
我们从去年年底开始都没休息好
真的花了很多很多心血
在想怎么去怎么去准备这些东西
然后写这些小引擎
有时候我们会说我们为什么辛苦干嘛呢
但是看到同学们在给我们取名字的时候
那份用心
那份真的把这个小引擎当成我们自己的一个
我叫做一个playground
就是我们自己玩的一个游乐场的感觉
突然一下子我们觉得心里很温暖温暖
比如像下有有有同学就给我们取了个名字
叫做啊叫做那个breaking亲
他说这就是我们自己的这个花园
我们一砖一瓦去构建它对吧
还有同学叫我们叫派引擎
什么意思
就是说诶
我希望这个小引擎能像太阳
无穷无尽的能够绵延下去
这这也是我觉得我们这个社区吧
大家最想看到的一件事情
就是说这门课程
就是虽然我们会有他的第一个part
这个finish的那个时候
但是我们一起通过这个小引擎
这个小社区在一起去连接
那么特别有意思的
还有人写诗
我这里面特别用了我们一个同学写的一首诗
叫做什么晴空一鹤排云上对吧
引得这个诗情
这个什么腾九霄
我觉得就太棒了
那个最后两个字我看不清楚
因为我被摄像机挡了
但是我当时看到这个词是我就是哇我的天呐
我都想把它打印出来
挂在我的办公室
就说嗯这是我们做引擎人的这个乐趣
所以说啊在before我开始今天的这个课程
之前的话呢
我还是再次的感谢一下我们社区
你们的小伙伴真的有你们的这些声音
有你们的支持
我们课程组做这个课程
在最更有动力好
那接下来就开始我今天课程的正文了
那今天的这节课程呢
我们就继续我们上一节课
那个的内容
就上一节课我们讲什么讲动画系统对吧
上一节课大家花了很长时间听我讲了
那么绕来绕去的四元数
讲了一大堆的公式
但是这个公式说实话比渲染还是少很多了
然后呢终于搞明白说唉呀给了一个一组骨骼
我到底怎么让这个骨骼动动起来
我这个骨骼动起来之后
我蒙这个蒙皮的一个网格
怎么样
像真的像人的皮肤一样
也能跟着骨骼去动
但是的话呢我们学了那么多
其实呢是一个基础的动画浏览
而今天这节课呢
我要跟大家讲一些高级的动画技术了
这些技术的话
实际上是现在现代游戏引擎技术里面
最实战的一些技术好
大家准备好冒险了吗
首先的话呢就是给大家看一下
这是我们上节课学的东西是什么
比如说我们理解了DCC动画是在DCC里面
怎么怎么通过控制那个骨骼的运动
做出我们各种各样的效果
然后呢我们也知道引擎怎么把这些动画导进去
怎么去做各种各样的蒙皮动画对吧
然后这个看上去我已经知道一切了然于心了
我们还知道什么叫做动画pipeline
但是大家想一想看
如果我用DCC
你生成了几十个
上百个甚至上千个这一个一个的动画
那它就是一个一个的动画
那为什么今天我们玩起现在这些游戏的时候
我发现他你们的这些角色的动画行云流水
你看不出来他是动画A动画B动画C
好像都是完全自然地连接在一起了
那这件事情是怎么发生的呢
这其实就是今天我们这节课要讲的重点
就是当我们有所有的这些动画的算法
我们知道有所有的动画素材的时候
怎么样的
让我们游戏里面这个角色真的按照我的意愿
活活灵活现起来那么好
所以呢第一趴也就是叫动画blending
也就是说
当我有几百上千的这个动画的素材的时候
我们叫做CLIPSE的时候
那么在游戏引擎中啊
我们不是依次的去播放它
或者是随机的播放它
我们实际上是要把很多的动画的素材
按照一定的规则
根据我的game play把它blender在一起
所以动画的blending
其实是动画的最重要的一个底层系统
那么在这里面的话
我们讲一个简单的例子
就是比如说还是我们小引擎的这个角色对吧
我们做了一个他走的动画
假设假设是0.1啊
1.5米每秒
那么我再做一个他跑的动画是3米每秒
那我现在假设这个角色我现在是从走逐渐到跑
从1.5米每秒
慢慢的到3米每秒
这个中间我怎么去过渡它的动画
我们不可能是说为每一个速度做过动画对吧
我相信学学到games104的同学都知道
游戏引擎绝对不会这么傻
我们多聪明啊
那我们就在想着怎么办
那么如果只是到了一个速度的
设个阈值切换的话
那就会出现在我们的这个
就是下面的第三张图里
你会看到一个很明显的切换
我们肯定也不会那么傻
所以同学们一定会一拍脑袋说
那不很简单吗
我们要做这个线性差值
也就是在你在第四张图看到的结果
就是诶
你能看到一个很smooth的这样的一个transition
从这个走路跑
这其实就是动画blending的一个
最基础的一个原理
也是而且这也是最经典的案例
就是为什么我们要动画要做blending
就是因为我们要无极变速好
那布兰妮怎么做呢
其实在上节课基本上讲的已经非常清楚了
就是learn对吧
线性差值
那我们讲的就是每一个joint
它它的无论它的平移
他的放缩
它的旋转
特别是旋转
因为旋转是最多嘛
那我们要去进行这个就是rotation的差值
那我们也讲到了quota的话
你可以用ENERP啊
你可以用ATHLOR
whatever什么ERP
但反正就是可以去做线性差值
但是呢不同于在上节课里面
我们的差值都是什么呢
比如说我有无数个key free
我去插值一个动画是什么呢
它本质上是在一个动画的clips内部
一直就是在真与真之间去插值
而这个差值呢就blending的差值呢
是在不同的动画
比如说在我走和跑的各取一帧进行差值
所以这是在两个clips之间差值
这一点的话是一定要分清楚的
因为所有的动画的blending
都是在多个CLIPSE之间来进行插值
那这个差值的话
我相信上完上一课的
上一节课的同学的话
一般应该知道这个算法该怎么写了
所以这地方我就不赘述了
而今天我们就讲一些这个乐谱
怎么这个这个这个blending怎么做
首先第一点就是我们怎么去算两边的权重对吧
那这个方法呢其实非常的直觉
就以我们这个数
就以这个从走到跑的这个案例吧
那么我们首先要引入一个我怎么算他的weight
其实非常的直觉
如果你是因为移动速度发生了变化
那我就用速度作为一个这个自变量
然后我可以推推导出来你的weight怎么变化
那假设我们的跑步的速度是这个speed2
走路的速度是speed1
那我其实可以根据当前的4B的
我就可以算出来
我的第一就是走路动画的VT1是多少
跑的动画V2多少
那大家只要保证V1加VT2等于一对吧
那我速度越来越快
我wait12的就是从0~1之间过渡
那就基本上就OK了
这个东西的话呢
我写了这一盘的话
同学们肯定觉得啊
这个我也会对吧
那这就是一个很简单的一个啊线性差值
根据这个那个你的靠近哪个信号
我去选择它的权重重一点
这是很直觉的好
接下来讲的这一趴呢是当我们做布兰妮的时候
特别容易忽视的问题
其实啊当我们在做这个动画CLIPSE的时候
其实首先能做这种差值的动画
很多时候我们希望它是循环的
大家想一想
当我在走路的时候
当我在跑的时候
我们的不平是不是不一样的对吧
我跑的时候不平会不会相对快一点
我走的时候步频相对短一点
那其实在这里面的话
我们这两个动画之间实际上是并不同步的
那你差值的时候
你该用我的跑的哪一帧
走的哪一帧呢
这个其实是在动画布莱尼系统里面
特别就是基本的一个问题
所以但是一开始大家做的时候很难会意识不到
所以这个时候我们就会要求动画师
在做动画的时候
你无论这个循环动画做多长
但是首先你必须是循环的
而且比如说假设走路动画都是左右脚各迈一次
那跑的动画也得是左右脚各迈一次
而且呢你就是那个脚落地的时间
最好大概是一致
这个时候我们要把它两个循环动画的时间规划
这样我的差值才能够保证说当我的时间
比如说是零的时候
我们的脚都没有提
0.5
0.25的时候诶
我的左脚踢到空中了
0.5的时候哎
左脚落下来了
0.75的时候
右脚踢到空中了
0.1的时候
右脚又落下来
要重新开始对吧
这个时间的timeline alignment
实际上是很多动画可以blender的一个基础
而且这里面就是让大家意识到
就是说其实动画的blender
它特别容易让你觉得直觉上非常的简单
非常的就是很好理解
但是的话呢如果你对这些基础的概念
如果理解的它不够准确的话
你特别容易写出各种各样的bug
比如说如果你的时间online做不好的话
比如说你的速度和这个差值没做好
你会发现这个人走路在地上就ice skating
就是说脚在地上滑步
这是为什么呢
比如说你的那个啊啊就是你的那个速度
他没有跟那个你的两边的权重
产生一个合理的关系
包括推进的那个步进的速度也没有配合的话
它就会产生滑步
而在游戏中的滑步
是一个我们一定要解决的问题
所以你有了这样一个非常简单的算法的话
你就完成了一个最简单的animation blending系统
你就可以得到任何一个无极变速的动画表情
看到这一趴的话
我相信很多同学都会觉得嗯我懂了
原来这个高端的游戏就是这么做的
就这么简单啊
确实就这么简单
比如说像我们的小引擎里面
好像已经实现了一个最简单的blending
但是的话呢它和我们真正的就是游戏引擎
你用的全套的动画系统来讲的话
还差得很远
但这个是一切的基础
好接下来我们再讲一点有意思的东西了
那其实啊你会发现这个blending
它实际上是有异味的变量
然后呢左右去控制它整个blending
那我们再讲一个有意思的事情
就是说假设我现在有一个这个角色
有一个向前走的这个动画
然后呢我还有一个叫向左走的动画
我还有一个向右走的动画
那大家想想看
我们在玩游戏的时候
这个角色是不受我控制
一会儿左
一会儿右
对不对
那实际上按照上一节课的那个思啊
按照上一趴的那个思想的话
是不是我可以让这个轴在左右之间自由的差值
然后选择在这个就是三个动画中的百分比对吧
那么这个差值叫什么呢
就是一维的blank space
但这里面大家注意一个细节啊
我这里只是举了三个采样点动画
刚才那个动画走和work的话啊
就work和run的话只有两个动画
我们只在两点之间差值
对不对
但是你发现没有
这里面把这个东西general generalize
就说虽然我还是一个一维这段差值
但是呢我的采样点不是两个了
是三个了对吧
那大家想想看
是不是我可以再加四个
再加五个
比如说我往左边慢移动和左边快移动
和站在中间直接往前走
还是往右边慢移动
往右边快移动
我可以变成五个采样动画
是不是也是一样的
所以说这里面有一个细节
就是说当我们做这个意维的动画的
这个bland space的话
实际上我们并没有规定这些采样点的总数
这些clip的总数
同时我们也并不要求
这些CLIPSE在这个轴上是均匀分布的
它可以有的时候密一点
有时候输一点
比如说人在正常走的时候
动画动作变化不大
但是他一旦开始侧翼的时候
他动作发生了很大的变化
很可能在一个很小的速度
我都切换成另外一个动画了
然后但是呢
当我在向更快的速度往侧面走的时候
这个速度动动作变化又没有那么大
直到发生显著的变化
我再切换到第三个动画
所以说它的分布其实也是可以不均匀的
这就是我们叫做blank space概念
那这是一维对吧
那同学们肯定会讲
你这个做的不完整的
因为我往就算我往前走
我可以走得快走得慢
我往左走一样也可以走得快
走的我甚至可以往斜走路方走
那怎么办
诶
这个时候很自然的
我们就需要一个二维的blank space
现在刚才大家讲的就是我站在中间
我是这个idol的
站在最下面那个点是idol的
我站在这不动诶
我我往前走的点是work
是是走的
我再往前走就run对吧
如果我的这个采样点只是往前走的话
我就是从idol到work到run的这样的一个变化
那同样的就是我在往左前方走出那个右前方左
我往这个这个就是说左前方跑
右前方跑
那整个这个角色的动画就会完全不一样
那这个时候我们是不是得到了一个二维的
一个采样空间
这个采样空间的每一个采样点
就是一个动画的素材
我们用它来表达这个角色的整个动画行为
大家注意啊
就是在这里面
Ban space man
所有的动画克里斯都是要求循环的
如果不循环
大家都不循环
就一次性播放网
如果要循环
大家所有人都循环
否则的话就会产生很多很奇怪的东西好
那但是呢我们的动画师呢
是观察生活非常细腻的人
他会告诉我们的游戏引擎程序员说
这个我们发现一个细节
就是说当这个人他从走到跑的时候
如果他加上横侧向移动的话
它会很快的进入到一个侧向跑的状态
因为侧向跑的时候人身体很难保持平衡
所以说如果它的速度只要超过一个简单的意识
他就开始必须要切换到跑的动画了
否则看上去很不真实
这个东西讲起来很细节啊
但是如果你们以后跟动画师团队去合作的时候
你会发现他们对人的动作的行为
就是肢体的这种变化是非常非常敏感的
这个时候就回到刚才我讲的那个概念
就是这些动画素材的话
在采用空间让它的分布其实是不均匀的
他们可以随机的散布在各个点上
也就是动画师觉得这个地方
我需要一个更细腻的表达
那个地方我可能会再加一个CLIPSE
那作为引擎程序员
我们怎么办
那好吧
随便你怎么放
我都理解了
然后接下来我们要去选择差值
但是你看这里面我们就有这么多动画了
对不对
你看这里面我们大概有七八个动画
那我难道每次不烂的时候
要把七八个动画不烂在一起
然后我就算他们的平均全中
这个呢好像这个计算机一个是比较费
因为我每一个动画CLIPSE
我首先要去算出来
他当前这一帧的动画是什么样子
然后我就要把七八个pose在一起进行blending
那这个计算量是不是会非常大
哎这个时候我们发现一个规律
就是我们用DRI3角化的方法
DN3角形是个数学方法
大家如果有兴趣的话
可以去查一下
其实非常简单
就是我给了你一堆二维空间的点
其实这个算法在三维也可以变成台球会哦
三维好像比较复杂
二维的话其实算法比较简单
我就是根据你的这些这些点
这些顶点我可以生成这个空间的三角形划分
那么你现在这个时候
你在任何一个速度这个轴上
你在任何一个方向
这个人就确定了二维空间一个唯一的点
那我就会选择临近的三个这个动画clips
然后呢用BIOCENTRIC
大家还记得我们在前面反复讲到的重心坐标
对吧
那个方法去在这个三个顶点里面
就三个动画的CLIPSE里面去插值
所以这个呢是一个完整的2D的
ban space的一个实现
而波兰space的话呢
在我们的游戏引擎早期是非常好的解决了
就是说艺术家只需要做几个角色行为的动画
但是呢我们可以在整个游戏引擎里面
实现一个非常丝滑的角色的运动
所以说我们的小引擎现在ban space还没有实现
所以说不定我们会把这个ban space
作为我们小引擎的一个作业
不给大家啊
现在我我我先不剧透
我只是说这是一个非常好的一个
就是做作业练习的一个东西
因为你会发现这个奇迹就会发生
就是说你本来看到一个很离散的动画
然后呢但是如果你有了一个ban space的话
你会发现你用你的摇杆去控制它的时候
唉无论以什么速度
无论你什么朝向这个角色的行为
看上去好像都很舒服
很smooth好
这就是tod black space的一个概念
这是我们在做动画的
这个就是real time的处理的时候
一个非常核心的
也是非常基本的一个数据单元
基本上现在游戏引擎
无论最高端的游戏吧
虽然我们讲很多游戏都是号称是这个
就是data driven的这个那个这个这个这个match making的
这个这个就是这个就是那个这样的一个动画
但实际上呢ban space的话呢
实际上还是一个非常基本的一个元素
很多地方还是要用到它那个
那接下来我们有了这样一个曲线方法
我们问题是不是解决了呢
我们发现又来了第二个问题
就是说
我们就这还是以我们的一个小机器人为例
他对特别喜欢大家
很欢迎大家来跟他玩
他要鼓掌对吧
但是我们小汽车有很多的pose
他可能一会儿站在这儿
他也可能蹲在这
大家觉得这个小机器人很可爱
那么我这个机器人甚至可能在走
那么在这样的一个情况下
我们还希望给他混合一个鼓掌的动画
但是我们知道鼓掌的动画
我不可能为每个姿势都做一个
我可能只能做上半身
但是我下半身的行为又会不一样
那怎么办
我相信聪明的同学们应该很快就能想到
很简单嘛
我们对skeleton做一个mask
就是说有些动画它只apply到你的上半身
有些动画呢我只apply到下半身
比如说我的下半身apply
一个这个人蹲在那儿的动画对吧
我的上半身呢apply
一个就是这个这个鼓掌的动画
我而且这个动画树那个
因为你只有这一部分的这个joints
参与了这个动画
它的动画的数据量是不是变得更小
而且因为你有这个mask
所以说当它apply到skeleton的时候
只要拍到一半的左右的骨骼
那我的计算量也会下降很多
这个时候我就可以自由的
把两种甚至更多的动画
在这个角色身上进行混合
这也是一种blending
就是skeleton mask blending
那你有了这样的一个API的话
或者这样的一个方法的话
你就可以实现这样的一个效果对吧
你就看到小机器人无论是什么造型
无论在什么位置都在鼓掌
欢迎我们
所以说这也是我觉得是个非常好的
小引擎的作业啊
大家可以拿这个效果来做这个作业
OK所以这是我们的叫做skeleton mask blending
好再给大家讲最后一种blending
假设我们对这个小引擎提出
这个机器人提出更高的要求
你不仅要对我鼓掌
你还要向我点头示意
这个这里面有有一个引擎的要求
叫做你要向着我去点头
因为鼓掌你可以这样对吧
你可以你可以可以这样
但是你的头我们希望机器人总始终朝着我
假设我做了个点头
我做了一个向前点头
向左点点头
向右点头
那这个时候我要让他有各种坐姿
我要让他这个手在不停的鼓
而且我还希望他的头看着我不停的点
而这个时候怎么做呢
其实这里面就有一个很重要的blending呢
我们叫做attitude blending
什么意思呢
就是在这一个动画里面
我们不仅只作用到这个skeleton的局局部
而且呢我们只存他的这个动画的这个变化量
而不而不至于那个就是存它的绝对量
这样的话我们在你无论怎么渲染的对吧
无论怎么动SKT的结构结果之上
我再加上一个extra的旋转呢
或者是这个translation啊
或者是这个scale
这个时候我们就可以在上面又去apply1层动画
这个时候你有这样的一个技术的话呢
诶你就可以实现这样的一个效果
就是你看到很多的机器人在这对
冲着你去点头了对吧
这个其实就是非常的简单
就是这个呢也就是在我刚才讲的三种补蓝顶
第一种是非常简单的LP
就是线性补蓝顶全身的
还有一种我们叫做mask blending
他只是对一个局部的进行blending
第三种呢叫做additive blending
就是说你们blending全部做完了之后
我再给你上面加一个修饰
加一个差分量
这三种不ending
基本上是游戏性里面blending的最主体的东西
那有了这个东西的话呢
呃我们基本上就可以做动画了
但这里面要讲一个细节
就是说其实这种editor blending啊
如果做的不好
是特别容易产生各种呃
我们称之为叫broken case的
就是比如说吧啊
我们这个角色本身做了一个转身的这个动作
他的脖子已经扭了
然后你再给他加上一个扭头
看别人的这个动作的话
他的脖子可能就超过了它的旋转的这个上限了
所以这个时候你这个角色看上去非常不自然
所以说adam blending的话
一般都会做起来非常的谨慎
而且这是我后面要讲的
就是在后面在规划这个角色运动的时候
我们会非常有意识地避免
就是过度的叠加这些动画
因为它会让有些joint的行为非常的异常
OK好
这个基本上就是我们的blending呢
就是这个三件套啊
应该是四件套吧
就是说首先大家理解什么叫一维和二维的这个
band space对吧
然后呢理解了非常简单的
就是说线性的或者是双线性的
或者三角形的边三角形差值的这种blending
然后呢我们理解了居skeleton mask的blending
还有呢就是说if blending
就是再加上你offset边那个
就是偏移量的种blending
那基本上你有了这些东西之后
你就可以把那几百个上千个动画
按照你想要的方法把它各种叠加在一起
根据你的game play
这个其实就已经可以做一些简单的小游戏了
其实如果你这时候不在乎
这个引擎是真的给artist用
你自己直接用来做游戏的话
有了这四个算法基本够用了好
那但是呢我们的这个引擎设计师是不满足的
为什么
因为我们的目标是要做工具
我们不是做算法
工具的目标是什么呢
就是我们要把它变成一个
可以教给我们的设计师
教给我们的艺术家
能够自由地构建他的世界的东西
那这里面我们对这个动画的表达呢
就会希望拥有一种更可视化的
更形式化的话去表达
这里面要介绍一个大名鼎鼎的概念
叫做呃animmation state machine
这个单词拼错了
不好意思
应该是呃也就action也可以
反正这个词我们有的时候一般都叫state machine
状态机
那么状态机的概念呢
为什么这个在动画中很重要
因为刚才我们只是讲了blending对吧
但是其实在动画系统中
他很多时候是状态在切换的
我们举一个非常简单的例子
就大家还记得在上一节课的时候
我们讲的就是说一个角色
我们作为一个跳起来的动画的时候
我们要把它的位移去掉
对不对
因为什么呢
因为在游戏中啊
这个角色跳多高
包括多久能落地
都不是动画能作死的
大家想象一下
比如说我站在一个斜坡上
我站在一个台阶上
我从台阶上跳下来
虽然我跳的高度是一定的
但是因为我跳下来这个台阶的深度我并不知道
所以我并不知道什么时候落地
所以一般我们会做三个动画
第一个动画呢就最上面的这个叫做起跳
第二个动画是什么呢
叫做空中的loop
也就是说你在空中浮空的时候
很优雅的把你的腿啊
手啊摆来摆去说啊
我现在飞在空中
I believe
i can fly对吧
那最后一个呢就是我的天
我要快落地了
这个时候呢有一个叫landing的动画
一般我们一个奖品实际上会拆成三个动画
这个时候你会发现你没有办法去blending它了
因为它不是个blending的问题
它是个什么呢
它是一个就是彼此依赖的一个状态切换的问题
就是当我决定按下一个button
比如说像XBOX经常按的是A键是吧
我记得A键就跳
那我按A的时候
或者XBOX那个叉那个PS圈的时候
诶
我播放这个角色起跳了
当这个角色跳到他的高点的时候
这个时候我应该播放什么东西呢
应该是在空中的那个loop哦
不是高点
就是说起跳动作播放完之后
我就要切到他的loop
为什么呢
那个时候因为他向上还有惯性嘛对吧
然后他就开始有惯性了
在那边
但他他就悬崖
那我并不知道他马上就要落下来
还是下面是一个无尽的悬崖
如果是无尽的悬崖
它就会一直这样啊啊啊这样摆
然后呢唉当它快落地的时候
我这个时候记住啊
这里面其实有个很复杂的东西
就是我不是说落地那一瞬间
我播放落地的动画
实际上是快落地的时候
一般是快落地的时候
我会让这个角色做出一种紧张的姿势
然后准备落地诶
我要播放这个落地的动画
当然这个这个是比较讲究的
如果你不那么讲究的话
是你检测它的位置到D的时候
你播放一个脚去削减势能的动作
Anyway
这个都可以
你会发现它是在三个状态里面是有序的切换的
而这个呢就是一个非常经典的状态机的要求
所以这个时候我们再去看动画的时候
就会不一样了
那我们就需要定义动画的状态机
那动画的状态机呢其实一般就有两种核心元素
第一个恒元素呢叫做它的这个节点
也就是说我们的动画的那个CLIPSE
就是原来的原始的动画素材
是它的节点
对不对
其实呢你可以把一个整个一个ban space
比如说我们的刚才讲的那个诶
前后左右这个在一起怎么混合
你也可以把它打包成一个节点对吧
你甚至可以把一个动画的蓝图都放进去做下
这里面我就借用于aria的概念吧
就是整个一个动画可以混合的速度可以放在去
它非常的灵活
那么但是呢这个里面它的
它最终产出的一定是一个动画
就是一个pose
一个pose to animmation
然后呢当这个东西呢它又满足了一定条件之后
它会从状态A就node a切到note b
就是我们叫STA或者到STB
所以叫动画的这个状态机的话呢
它实际上核心的元素就是一个可以反复循环
或者叫循环输出动画的这样的一个
就是这个它的state或者叫做note
还有什么呢
就是满足条件
我就自动的从这个node a切到node b的这样的
一个过程
回到刚才我们那个案例里面
这里面是一个非常简单的这个SM的一个案例
就是你从爱豆开始
当我收到了这个玩家跳起来的这个动画的时候
我可能就会进入到jump的那个新jump那个节点
那jump那个节点首先是jump start是吧
然后在jump loop这个jump
首先jump star
他可能觉得哎我到了高点的时候
jump star就停掉了
我就变成jump loop
这个JBLOOP里面啊
它一直会循环
直到他说我要落地了
这个时候这个状态就切换到a landing
到landing之后
landing他要把自己播完之后
他才能回到这个人的idol
所以这你只有这样的一个系统的话呢
这个角色的行为才是看上去是自然的
那么这里面的transition的话呢
其实就比较复杂
我这里面给出了一个最简单的定义
比如说你只需要知道它的起点是谁
它的终点是谁对吧
那么这里面的话你还说哎
我之间要不要去做这个差值啊
如果差值的话
我从动画A的话
B不要马上过来
我中间有一个布兰妮的过程
可能是比如说0.2秒
0.3秒
0.2秒是我以前我们以前经常用的一个magic number
我也不知道为什么很多artist都喜欢填0.2秒
好像这个数字看上去就那么舒服
但其实真正复杂的是什么
是这个transition是在什么时候激活
待会儿我们会讲就是它其实有很多的条件出发
而且呢这里面讲一个比较复杂的概念
就是一个完整的动画状态机的实现的话
它的transition条件可能是不止一个的
可能是很多个好
那这里面就讲一个fade
这个fade呢讲一个非常简单的一个数学原理
就是fade一般有两种
一种就是我从动画一到动画二之间
就是动画一越来它的它的贡献量越来越少
动画二的贡献量越来越越多对吧
这是一个非常容易理解的一种差值
就是smooth transition
但是的话呢其实还有一种是什么呢
就是frozen transition
就是说我的动画一要切动画二的时候
我动画一呢先停住
然后呢动画二这个时候逐渐逐渐的进来
但是这个是基于你现在动画一的这个基础
这件事情有点抽象
比较难理解啊
但是实际上的话呢在我们的动画系统中
真的是有用处的
就是有些动作当你要发生切换的时候
你继续在播放动动作一的这个动作的话
它和动作二在一起混合的时候
看上去反而更不自然
就以刚才这个起跳为例的话
如果你之前用smooth transition的话
你会觉得这个人在空中还在试图跑步
再怎么样
这当然也是一种这个跨栏的演示方法了
但是呢动画二那种
就是说frozen那个这个transition的话呢
你会觉得诶这个人好像试图停一下
在原地起跳
你说到底哪个好呢
我觉得这个是artist决定的
但作为我们的engine designer的话呢
我们实际上要给大家提供一个选项
这你们再多说一句
就是说其实啊这个两个信号之间的fade
是有非常多讲究的
就大家啊看到这里面这么多
名目繁多的曲线对吧
其实本质上就是要接
还记得我以前跟大家讲
那个就是那个那个那个就是那个啊
材质模型的时候就讲过
说诶这个这个信号到底要尖锐一点呢
还是下面的
还是下面的波峰要拖得再长一点
其实大家都只是在找各种各样的可能的形状
比较多的形状就两种
一种是linear
就是线性的差值对吧
还有一种是什么呢
我们叫做easy easy out
什么意思
就是用cubic的方法
或者用BASA曲线
就是A先平平的在中间长得比较快一点
到结束的时候再慢一点
这个是用的比较多的
其他的其实像什么指数啊
这些东西至少在我们的动画系统里面
用的是比较少的
你会发现动画是大部分时候要么就是线性差值
要么就是这个EZEZL的差值
但是呢不妨碍大家知道这些基础的这个理论
因为这个东西的话
其实在我们的引擎很多地方都会用到
比如后面我讲的party系统的时候
他的很多particle的这个这个这个明暗的变化
可能就要用这种这些曲线来表达
那这里面的话呢给大家举一个真实的案例
就是说这是用unreal引擎做了一个案例吧
这是一个一个一个ASM的案例
那在这里面
大家看到那个上面每一个小小的那个双箭头
其实就表示了一个transition
你打开那个transition的话
你看到里面有很多的属性
这里的属性比较复杂
我就不一一展开了
那这里面的话你会看到就是说哎
他这里面你看的特别清楚的是
我的这个duration到底要插值多久
包括呢我大概是什么样的一种插值类型
它单这里面有一个比较复杂的东西
在这个图上没有展开出来
就是我这个什么时候发生
这个transition的条件到底是什么
对吧
这个地方其实非常的有意思
然后呢再讲给大家讲
这个我我在后面讲
但这里面大家注意到一件事情
就是说其实这里面的每一个每一个note
或者叫每一个st
它不是大家想象中非常简单的一个动画的素材
实际上呢这里面的话
你点开来可以发现
它可以做成一个非常复杂的一个动画蓝图
就是很多很多动画
在你们又按照一定的规则去融合
当然你也可以只放一个
比如刚才我们在前面讲的一个ED的VD
或者2D的这个two d的这个blank space
这都可以
其实这也是为什么
我我这节课在讲动画树的时候啊
我大量的用了unreal做案例
因为其实我们比较下来
我个人认为
荣耀的这个动画系统设计的是非常好的
它一个很大的我认为设计的比较好的地方
就在于就是说它实际上非常灵活
你可以根据自己的需要自由的嵌套
自由的组合
而且呢它的很多的这个图标啊
包括交互设计啊
非常符合设计师的直觉
所以如果诸位想做游戏引擎
想做游戏引擎
你的这个动画树系统的话
或者叫动画蓝图系统的话
我觉得要是一个非常好的一个参考
而且也非常符合我们讲动画系统这个概念好
那其实呢当我们有了这个就是动画状态机的
这个基础的话
我们真实的在游戏中的表达一个角色的时候呢
在最古典的时代
我们用的一个东西叫做layered a s m
就是多层次的这个动画状态机
比如说这个角色的上半身
我们有一套复杂的状态机
比如说表达他
比如受击啊
或者说他各种攻击别人的动作啊
然后下半身的话呢我会根据我的一玩家的control
比如说哎我这个角色在跑跳走对吧
然后的话呢我两层东西叠在一起
就是这个上一个管
上面那个管下半身
还有个人可能管这个头
还有的还有一层可能是管这个这个角色的受击
所以你几层状态机做好之后
基本上能够在游戏中表达一个
活灵活现的这样的一个角色
这里面我举了个例子
比如像鬼泣五的这个例子
你会发现这个角色为什么你觉得很有打击感
因为他下身跳的各种动作
和他上身打怪的各种攻击动作
是基本上是可以独立控制的
这样你会觉得这个角色特别的火
而不那么僵对吧
这就是layer sm的一个很大的好处
那这也是一个最经典的一个设计
但是的话呢就是说现代游戏引擎里面
我们基本上切到了什么呢
就是动画树了
那动画树这个概念
我相信同学们应该至少虽然没有用过吧
或者很多同学已经用过了
应该是久仰大名了
那动画树最原始的这个idea
至少我个人的理解啊
是从表达式数开始的
因为大家想想看
如果我layer的SM无非不就是信号
A加B加C加D嘛对吧
那其实我们对整个动画的表达
实际上可以表达成一种
就是比如说速度空运算对吧
动画A加动画B然后呢可能在TV点C对吧
再再受制于什么东西
所以说这个东西其实如果是这样的
一个表达式的话
我们是不是用一个数的形式是不是更好
所以大家仔细看动画树啊
其实动画树的话
它其实是一个就是一个一个单向展开的一个数
它并不是一个图
它最终一定要有一个流出的这个节点
就像你作为一个表达式数一样
最终有一个中有一个那个根节点好
那动画树呢它你们的节点就像我前面介绍过的
其实非常的简单
比如说它最最常用的就是线性插值节点
但大家注意啊
在动画树里面
线性插值节点的一
最简单的二元线性差值的话呢
你输出的是个权重对吧
比如说零就零就表示这个我全部选用CLIPA
如果一的话
我就全部选用cb ca cb
那我加0.5的话各取一半
那么但是的话呢
这个这个这个系统还是三通道的系统
这个时候呢它的权重我们一般会单独让你输入
就是VT1
Vt 2v3
你自己来控制它对吧
这个很像是不是很像那个电路板
然后呢如包括刚才我们讲的editing blending
在动画树里面也有专门的节点
你可以把它放进去
也可以做你想做的事情
那么这个时候去刚才我们讲的lay了
SM的话
是不是可以很轻松的用这样的一个结构的
动画树就可以表达出来
所以说啊动画树呢
你可以认为是layered sm的一个超级
那么也就是说它可以做表达
所有的layered sm能表达的东西
但是动画树呢它真正的酷的地方就在于
它实际上是一个递归结构
至少我在这个游戏引擎
现在游戏引擎里面
我看到大家越来越把它变得更general
举个例子就是这里面我还是不得不highlight的一下
就是那个虚幻引擎
就是说他在动画树的节点设计中非常的灵活
就是说它既可以是一个动画的素材
也可以是一个就是那个ban space
也可以是一个ASM
这样的话你最终只要输出一个节点就可以了
刚才我讲了那个一个ASM
就是说动画状态机点开了之后
它里面又屏内嵌很多的note
这些note中间呢又可以在内嵌一颗小动画树对吧
这个听上去就很丧心病狂了
你这个就是就是你套我
我套你
但这东西你觉得很复杂吧
但其实如果写过编程的同学
就知道我的类的定义
类的时间就可以
你套我我套里
就是这个代码就可以互相套起来嘛
所以的话呢这些数据怎么去组织
怎么去归类
实际上这个结构就给我们的设计师提供了一个
非常大的一个一个自定义的空间
那么看这些节点呢
我们一般都叫做叶节点
那么在业绩点往上的话呢
我们有很多这种中间的计算机点
最常见的就是刚才我讲的就是各种loop节点
对吧
你无论是additive还是这个mask的
还是这个只是二两通道的
三通道的还是多通道的
那么就是说这里面的话呢是一个非常简单的
这个就是unreal animmation blueprint
这样一个案例
大家可以看到就是说两个就是ASM
就是动画状态机
他们的输出就接受了一个控制信号
诶输出了最终玩家的这个动作
这里面的话呢我们要讲的就是说
听上去好像很简单
但是这一棵动画树放在这儿的话
它为什么可以一直在变换它的输出
对不对
你这样说
你的数的数据放在那是静态的
它为什么可以根据我的鼠标的啊
鼠标键盘的输出
包括游戏的状态
它会产生不同的pose呢
这里面呢有一个关键的东西
就是说其实动画树它最核心的
你要定义它的控制变量
也就是说在这个动画树中的话
我们会定义大量的这个变量
暴露给外面的game play系统
它来控制
就是说A他会告诉你说
比如说我现在的移动速度
我现在的朝向
我现在的健康状态
我是不是现在要跳起来
比如说我现在是不是受到了别人的攻击
而这些大量的控制变量的话
实际上就会改变这棵树里面的什么呢
混合行为
你可以想象成
就是动画树是无数个流着水的管道管
每个管道汇在一起的话
它有一个阀门会控制说我用红颜色的水
液体多一点
还是蓝颜色的液体多一点
这个阀门呢就是用控制变量来控制的
那我假设有12种颜色对吧
按照各种数学规律
我预先放好在这边可以一层层的混合的时候
那我只要输入这个阀门的控制变量的话
是不是就可以决定最终流出来
混合出来的那个液体
那个水的颜色
大家想象一下
假设一个有颜色的水管的话
是不是这样一个逻辑
实际上动画树的控制变量
实际上是动画树的灵魂
它能控制住整个行为
那这个这里面这个讲起来就比较复杂了
就非常的多
但这里面给大家讲一个基本的概念
比如说呃在虚幻引擎里面
就这举他例子
它定义类东西叫VERABLE
其实我们一般也会定义这个词叫VERABLE
就是说这个一个变量它会暴露出来
然后呢这里web大家注意有两类
一类呢就是环境的一些参数
就像刚才我讲的
比如我的速度
我的朝向
我的健康值对吧
我会根据我的健康值
比如说我现在血量只有一半了
那我的动作可能会切换到那种哎呀
很虚弱的那种动作
这种动作可能动画是体现做好了
如果呢诶我血量很满
那我这时候动作是另外一组动作
走起来这个昂首挺步的
反正两组动作我都是混合在这
但是呢那个开关就取决于我的血量
是不是大于50%
这个是不是很好理解对吧
这是一种
还有一种是什么呢
我们称之为叫做event
就是说当一件事情发生的时候
我会去修改一些变量
但这个修改呢一般来讲是event发生的时候
我会把动画树里面的一些局部的一些
标记给修改掉
举个例子
比如说现在我手上拿了一把步枪对吧
我突然这个接到一个指令
说我要把步枪换成一个火箭筒好了
那这个时候我拿枪
我的动画
上半身的动画就会彻底的从这样的一个动作
变成了这样的一个动作躺在这儿了对吧
那这个信号呢一旦来的时候
我就会修改我动画树内部的一些状态里面
就我们一般就如果大家有编程的技术的话
你可以认为这就是类中间的这个private的
这个就是我私有的这个变量
但是呢它可以被外部的一个状态激活并且修改
所以其实大家对动画树的理解
你可以理解成它有两趴
第一趴呢是决定这些动画像流水一样的
各种颜色的动画
通过这些阀门控制它怎么去混合
那这个阀门怎么控制呢
其实在动画树中呢还有很大的一块代码啊
有一块这个计算机构去算
我每个阀门的开放的百分比
那这些呢就通过我的变量
通过外部的控制信号
来在动画树中进行一些简单的加减乘除比较
或者说那个对那这这这些运算是最常见的
能实现我想要的效果
所以呢大家如果真的想实现一个高级的
就是动画树的这个动画系统的话呢
那我会非常建议大家去认真的研究一下
这个虚幻引擎
因为它是我目前见过做得非常完备的一个系统
那么这里面的话呢
你会看见你会理解这里面基本的概念
而这节课上的话呢
我觉得我把这些最基础的概念教给大家
就是说实际上你有了这两层概念的话
你基本上就能够搭建一个动画树系统
比如说你现在想做个引擎的话
你说哎呀这个太复杂了
我搞不了这么多
其实很简单
你可以定义一些接口的一些啊一些变量
这些变量的话呢让你的game play系统可以去修改它
而你的动画系统呢做好了之后
它在每个节点读取这些变量
然后呢你允许它支持一些简单的
比如说加减乘除
比较大小或者是等于的运算
实际上呢你也可以实现一个A
有点那么个意思的动画系统了
所以说我们土法炼钢也也是可以练出来的
那么这里面的话呢就是一个哎这个气
这其实是按荣耀五里面一个最基础的一个
动画树的教程
他其实这个教程讲的就比较清楚
131313的就动画树的其实实现了流派啊
每一家厂商其实都有点区别
比如说你看dice引擎就是death fb引擎的话
它会也有很多自己的节点对吧
因为根据产品不同
游戏不同
但是呢最基础的概念基本上就是这样
大家是大同小异的
大家知道了动画树这些东西啊
其实我们一个角色的动画系统
就角色的运动基本上就能表现出来
你能够表现这个角色
是让这个跟这个games play环境连接在一起
但是呢角色它的运他的动画呀不是孤立的
它实际上是和环境在一起的
而且跟环境在一起呢
他这跟环境有很多对他的约束
所以这里面我会跟大家先讲几个基本的概念
就是说其实我们前面讲的所有的动画
它是什么呢
它是我们叫做forward condemics
也就是说我们去驱动关节
从根到上一节节往前走对吧
动画树的混合也是这个道理
就是驱动往前就是这个forward的
就是往前传递的这样的一个动力学的东西
但是呢反向动力学inverse conomics的意思是什么呢
就是说哎假设我约束好
我就是要让你的手抓到这个点
那你这个动画该怎么做
对不对
就是我我现在前排
上节课我们已经提到这个概念对吧
这样的一个有约束的这个反向去解
你每一个joint怎么用的话呢
我们叫做反向动力学
而这个东西呢其实在游戏中非常的有用
比如说那个最经典的就是游戏中
你能抓到一个把手对吧
你能够这个这个这个摔跤的时候
你能抓到一个人
那么其实呢在游戏引擎中
我们怎么样的帮助设计师
帮助这个就是去表达说
我希望这个爵士的某一个骨骼的运动
符合我这个反向动力学的约束呢
我们叫做and effecture
就是末端的这个这个这个效果器
那么也就是说我们会在这个股上说
我要加个n effect
我希望它总是能够贴到地上
这是什么
这就是贴地的需求对吧
那在这里面的话呢
一个最经典的案例
就是说当角色在一个颠簸不平的地上走的时候
我们希望它的脚总是踩在地面上
但是动画树做动画的时候
大家如果看过动画师做的动画
它永远假设面前是一望无垠的平地的
所以大家看早期游戏的时候
那些角色都是在地上
就是这样
就是各种乱踩一漆皮
特别明显的就是上楼梯嘛
所以在这种情况下呢
我们特别希望就是哎呀
有一个大神能够在我这个角色迈出去
每一步的时候
他都能够帮助这个角色
就是把他的脚按在那个地面之上
那这些怎么怎么解决呢
其实最简单的解决方法叫做a two bone ik
就只有两个B约束的
IK就是以这个人的为例的话
那么他的大腿和他的小腿那个两根骨头
是不是代表了三角形的两个边
然后呢我的目标点也确定了
那其实目标点离我这个就是大腿根部的
这个距离的话
是不是也是去年
那我就知道了
三条边长
三条边长的话呢
其实我们就可以唯一的确定一个三角形
因为一个最简单的这个这个初中的三角函数
我们就可以知道说你的大腿要迈多少度
小腿迈了多少度
我就可以算出你的动画
这个呢就是一个非常简单的max叫two pi k对吧
用一个简单的两个球球教的问题
但是呢这里面有个比较讨厌的事情是什么呢
就是当我去给定一个约束点
给定一个大小腿的这两个骨骼的时候
你会发现它的解是其实相当于它的解空间
是两个球的交点
它解除了一个圆环
也就是在圆环上的任何一个点的话
这个解都是有效的
所以就以这个角色为例的话
大家是不是发现
他无论是内八字还是外八字对吧
他这个动作实际上都是可以
保证他的脚踩的那个点的
但是这个的话我们的艺术家肯定是不答应的
那咱们解决这个问题呢也非常的简单
那我们让艺术家呢说你这个人不是往前走吗
那你给我一个reference vector
告诉我说
如果我需要做IK我的腿
他的整个这个朝向应该朝什么方向好
那我就在沿着那个朝向的方向
去找他的那个姐姐
这个解法其实非常的简单
就是说我通过那个我求一个
因为你给了我一个REFERVOR
再加上我的那个大腿的这个
这个和卧底目的点的连线
我可以确定一个平面对吧
拿了个平面和那个圆环一一交点
肯定就有两个交点
那其中有一个交点是正向的
一个焦点是反向的
用一个简单的三角
那个就是那个就是那个vector的这个cross
就是呃不是cross rector dot
就向量的点击大于零
就是同向小于零
就是逆向
你就可以解释那个点了
这个时候你就基本上可以非常完美的解决
这个就是脚踩在地上的问题
而且这也是IK最简单的方式
但是呢这个世界上的事情就是不是那么简单
就是如果这个事情这么简单
我们就很开心了
事实上的话呢
IK的scenario比这个要复杂很多了
比如说我们要让这个角色看一个方向
look up对吧
那我们在角色这个脖子这个地方
其实有很多根骨骼的
包括当我们的角色在空中飞舞的时候
它要抓住一个东西
包括呢就是说我们在游戏中的话呢
其实有很多这种上下左右翻飞全身的这种IK
那么这个IP真正难的地方在哪里呢
就是说如果你参与这个IK的这个join的
不止两个
你有一条链的时候
你怎么去写对吧
他有两个问题
第一个就是说这个自由度太高
自由度太高
大家觉得在方程中啊
就是表示他的他那个high dimension高维方程
而且它是个非线性的方程
因为它有大量的旋转角度
角角度在里面
它不是个线性方程
所以接下来很蛋疼
那第二件事情呢
关键是它的解有无穷多个
就以刚才以就就以这张图上为例的话
你连接了这个起点和目标点
它的joint是不是有很多种可能性
实际上它是无限种多种可能性
所以在游戏引擎里面
我们怎么能解决这种常见的这种IK呢
那这里面的话呢呃我们首先第一件事情是说
我们得判断这玩意能不能够能不能够得着
因为你想你花了半天
写一个常见的这个IK问题的话
如果他本来就够不着
我们是不是在浪费我们的时间
这里面给大家讲两个非常简单的这个东西
就是说在大家在解决这种真正的IK问题的
比如说我要用身体去购置一个苹果
就比如说这时候我刚好两个胳膊不够
我这身体还要前倾的话
你首先要判断我能不能够得着它
有一个最简单的方法
但这个方法其实是后面会讲
他其实是不完整的
就是说哎我把所有的骨骼全拉直了
我的长度够不够
如果长度不够
我是不是肯定是不够的
对不对
第二种是什么呢
我把最长的一根骨骼放在这
我把所有的骨骼对着它去折
如果这两个这些骨骼无论怎么折的话
它他没有办法覆盖那个最长的骨骼
其实我在我的靠近我的区域
其实也有一个盲区
这个是大家在写这种IK的时候
经常会忽略的事情
然后呢你会发现你在解了很久
就是拿不到一个解
然后有的时候如果上面写的不好
他就会无限次迭代下去
这就会在会在这个地方去踩坑
那么那接下来拿到这个东西的时候
我们怎么怎么去解呢
那这边还有更难的一个问题是什么呢
就是实际上对于一个人形的这个角色来讲
我们的骨骼是不能乱动的
其实我们每个joint
它的活动范围都是有他自己的约束的
比如说我们脚那个大腿和这个
就是和跨这个地方的话
是一个标准的一个叫球状的这个关节
就是它是你会发现大腿身上的骨头像个小圆球
然后它在你的这个盆骨那边诶
可以来回转转转转转对吧
然后呢你的脚踝那个地方和那个脚
就是脚踝和那个上上面那个腿
下小腿骨那个地方那个关节的话呢
它这个可以平移的这样的一个像小磨盘
也在平一面对吧
那我们的脖子这个地方是什么呢
像个pivot
它可以这样转来转去
那我们最熟悉的比如说像手掌
手掌是个什么呢
是个叫马鞍面的关节
叫SEL这种马鞍型的关节
然后呢你会发现为什么手掌我可以前后这样转
很方便
但是诶我这样转的时候
好像活动方面就有限了
怎么样做游戏引擎有意思吧
你会发现我们上次讲做渲染的时候
大家觉得诶你要上懂天文
下懂地理
接下来就说哎呀
我做游戏引擎
我还成为一个解剖学家
你还要理解人体的骨骼结构确实是这样
就是其实如果我们要想把一个角色做的好的话
我们确实需要知道你的这个解剖型结构
大概是怎么回事
这个东西叫什么呢
这叫constrain of joints
就是说我当我去做一个人体的skeleton的时候
就bypad skeleton的时候
他每个joy是有它的一个特定的活动范围的
而这个时候我们放到一起再去解它的话
这是不是很痛苦
所以这就是IK啊
就是对于常练的AK很蛋疼的一件事情
好那这里面的话呢我们先讲一讲这个东西
就是为什么这么重要
比如说大家看在这这里面我选了几个游戏啊
这是我们课程组的小伙伴找到了
我觉得他们真的很棒
真的找到了
勾起了我很多童年的回忆
就是大家一定记得在游戏里面
各种各样的这个这个这个有趣的镜头对吧
其实都是IK惹的祸
因为他的join的那个约束没有控制好之后
方程解报了
然后你会发现当比如说像他最右边的
最左边的那个时候
这个球员他在开球的时候
因为他一脚踢到另外一个人
他就开始解AK了
结果解错了
整个人这个就解解非解炸掉了对吧
那这里面这个裁判也是一样的
就是说他因为撞到了一个人
他整个这个手的姿势全部扭掉了
最有最有趣的就是这个探员
你看他的脑袋啪撞了一个将近360度
所以其实我们在玩游戏的时候
经特别是那种受击动画
特别是那种特别剧烈的动画
你很容易会hit到这种IK导致的
这个这个这个一些很weird的一些situation
所以这就是为什么CONSTRAME这是非常重要
在我们的AK系统中好
先不吓唬大家
就是说这里面的话呢
我们今天会介绍几个非常经典的算法
这个算法都不是我尽可能会讲的比较简单
那么尽可能放水啊
我今天就争取能放放水
那么其实跟大家讲它的核心速度是什么呢
我们首先用最heuristic的
就是说启发式的算法去解决它
因为你真的解决那么复杂的这个
高维非线性方程啊
这个其实很麻烦
就是你当然你可以用语有些线程的数值方法
但是那个方法第一个本身它不一定稳定
第二个它非常的expensive
所以呢我们的这个engineer的话
在游戏引擎研发中啊
确实非常的聪明
引入了一些算法
比如说最著名的一个算法
我认为就是CCD算法
这个算法其实想想法非常的简单
就是你不是要向目标点吗
那很简单
我把你的节点最末端那个那个那个joint
我先呢把它往这个你的上一根的joint
和那个目标点之间的连线方向去翻
这样我就把我就靠近他
对不对
这个时候呢我再去翻下一根骨头
也是以以此类推
我就一路翻一翻
你就会感觉这个整个这个骨头
是尝试往东端点不变
尝试往那个目标那个地方去翻滚
然后这个时候呢
我再把这个算法再从端点再做一遍
这个时候你如果一开始是内翻的话
那么下一趴是不是应该外翻诶
当你进行若干次这样迭代的时候
你会发现你会越来越接近对吧
最终几乎是完全重合在那个目标点上了
这个方法呢就叫做CCD
其实非常的简单和淳朴
但这里面注意一个细节
就是这个事例中你会觉得好像第一次诶
就基本就翻到了对吧
但实际上在真实的游戏里面的话
这种CCD迭代隔十几次很正常
但他每一次计算呢其实也不复杂
这也是一个目前行业里面大家觉得最经典的
也是最简单的一个多练的一个IK算法
那么当然CCD呢我们可以对他做很多的优化
比如说你看这个算法会出一个问题
就是说哎一开始你放的太猛烈了
猛烈的点到后面呢
你翻的好像觉得这个感觉就没有那么点意思
感觉这个人
就比如说你这个上半身已经歪的已经不行了
但是你的腰好像还是笔直的
就感觉不对
诶他后面就会做很多的优化
比如说诶我每一次我方的那个目标点
一开始呢我在目标点做一个相对大的一个范围
你方的大致到那个目标点
目标点就差不多了
然后呢我第二次迭代的时候
我逐渐往那个中心点去收缩
让它看起来更像一点
或者说呢我每一次翻的时候
我的角度变化
我给它设个上限
不允许你超过这个变化
这样的话也能够让这个旋转的话
在整个骨骼上均摊一点
那这个它的数学原理是什么呢
首先我给我得给实话实说
跟大家承认啊
这全是骇客
他的数学原理是什么呢
就是说其实我认为就是表面的这种呃弹簧吧
它的内部的能量最低
就是假设我们原始的骨骼状态
是一个已经固定好的一个弹簧
那你去掰每个joint的时候
那个掰的角度越大
它是不是那个弹性的那个系数
就会有那个那个能量
就那个势能就越大
储存在弹簧里面
对不对
那你把一个joy的搬的很多的话
它能量是以二次方往里面去涨对吧
哎他现在的意思就是说
大家想象一个一个无数个弹簧联想的链条
如果你掰它两头的时候
它是不是呢相对均匀的把这个这个把这个形变
或者把这个joint的这个这个bad band
在这个joint之间去分散的
它本质上要的是这么一个结果
但只是啊找了无数的hack
所以其实啊我们在理解各种IK算法的时候
你用这个弹簧的这个连接棒的模型的话
你就能理解它的算法到底为什么会这么设计
那么其实呢这个里面如果我们假设
就是说那个在做一些更自然的
一些一些旋转的话
其实也就这个原理
比如说我们会让越比如说我们可以约定说
越靠近根节点的那个那个那个它的旋转
这个幅度就越小
越在业界点的话
旋转速度越大
其实也符合我们讲这个总体的势能
向偏小的方向去旋转的这样一个原则
这是一个非常简单好用的算法
其实如果同学们有兴趣的话
可以自己写一下
要不我们把这个CCD作为我们的动画系统
作业的题目对吧
也我觉得这个题目也非常好
因为这也是我特别喜欢的那种小算法
那么这里面还要介绍另外一个大名鼎鼎的算法
我们叫做fabric
发给这个名字
听上去非常的高大上
但其实他翻译起来非常的直觉
叫做forward and backward
reaching inverse condemics对吧
那后面两个词就是IK了对吧
就是前面四个字呢
说人话就是我向前去迭代一遍
我向后再去迭代一遍
然后呢我就反复的来来回回
我解决了AK问题
所以大家记HRC就这么记就好了
那FACTK的原理其实呢这个非常的简单
就是说它不同于CCD啊
就是我老是把那些骨骼掰来掰去的嘛
他说哎呀你们太麻烦了
我只做他的位移
就是他的想法是说我先从这个端点开始
把第一个joint
强行的拉到那个目标点那个地方去
然后呢我再根据他的上一个那个join
还没有动的那个join
和那个目标点之间连一根线
我再把骨骼旋转的那个那个连线上去
但是呢这样的话
因为骨骼的长度固定在哪嘛
所以我一定会滋出去
对不对
好
我呲出去了之后
那我下一根骨要跟我连
对不对
好
下一个骨骼
也是就把我支出去的那个反向的那个端点
作为他的目标点
也跟他去对上了
然后呢还以此无法炮制
就一个一个往上窜
一直穿到最后一根根节点的骨骼
那这样会出现什么结果呢
就出现了那个根节点结飞了
对不对对吧
就是我我为了让你们去凑那个目标点
所以我把我的根据点动了
诶这个时候他的backward power就来了
说哎呀这样不行啊
那我自从我把这个整个链条倒过来
我从那个根节点开始
先把根节点拉回到原来的那个原点
诶它又发生了偏移
然后一次哒哒哒哒哒哒
一路拉到他的这个他的那个这个这头的端头
那这样这头端头就会出现一些误差
但是呢一般你这样迭代啊
你会发现经过这一来一回啊
你首先是把这个这个原始五个根节点
还是锁住了
同时呢这个整个骨骼链还是满足了我们的约束
但是呢这个时候他最远端的那根骨骼
离目标点的距离明显就会近很多了
除非你这个目目标达不到啊
这个时候我们再如法炮制
再来一遍
就是这个forward and backward
Forward
Backward
经过若干次迭代
你你会发现诶
我的这个端点就会非常接近于我的目标点
但是这两个算法无论是CCD还是fabric
我个人觉得他都要设置一个ERROTOLERANCE
好像是他也不能完全保证
你就一定能够hit到哪个目标目标点
但是的话呢
就是说基本上能够得到一个
我们可以接受的结果
包括写fabric这个算法
最早的这个老哥的论文的话
我们前段前段时间备课的时候
我们还查了一遍
结果这个老哥在论文中
clan说我这个算法效率要比CCD更高
然后当时我就在想
那为什么在行业里面到现在我们还在用CCD呢
两个就是两个都在平行在用
也没说这个一个取代掉谁对吧
后来我发现这个老哥给的所有的性能的数据
大家知道MAD lab这个东西的话呢
它的性能和真实的就是引擎跑出来的性能
是没有可比性的
所以呢我后来就想还是算了
我就不用他这个结论了
我也不敢说fabric一定比CCD快
但是呢这是目前在做这个IK的话
如果你想做一个简单的常量IK的话
最主流的两个算法好
那么fabric的话呢其实跟CCD一样的
它也能处理一些
就是我们叫做这个啊约束的问题
实际上的话呢就是当你有约束的时候
fabric的话它其实非常的简单
就是说你第一个链条你一动的时候
你根据你约束的这个转动范围诶
我去求一个垂直平面
然后呢我在上面投影
我那个投影点作为我的target的点
这样我把我的第一个就让你的动掉
然后呢如果每个骨骼都有join
都有那个约束的话呢
我就依次这样去投
其实这跟刚才讲CCD啊那个道理一样
刚才CD那一趴我没有讲
其实CCD也能够去处理约束他的核心的思想
就是说我谷歌每次动的时候
我不要超过那个约束就好了
这样的话
就等于说我第一次这根骨够不着的时候
我就交给第二根骨骼去够
这样的话实际上也能解决骨骼约束的问题
但是呢他们两个共同的问题
都是说需要无数次的来回迭代
比如说一个几十根骨骼的链条的话
迭代个几十次是很正常的好
那其实呢刚才讲的所有的约束啊
它都比较简单
就是说它都是一个单一的约束点
但是真正在游戏引擎中啊
我们经常会发现我们游戏输出点特别多
举个例子
比如说攀岩对吧
那这个时候你的左脚
你的右脚都要分别踩到岩石哪个地方
你的手还得够到另外一个点
那你整个这个角色这个skeleton啊
整个被拉伸的
所以大家想象一下
就说为什么我们经常开玩笑说
育碧大育碧爬墙党
我们总是在这样的嘲讽一笔
但是呢今天的话我们讲到动画这一趴的时候
我得给他们这个稍微这个洗脱点罪名
因为实际上你要做一个爬墙的时候
活灵活现的这样一个character的话
从动画系统来讲的话
门槛其实是非常高的
因为最难的就是它的整个一个IK和动画
混合的体现
也就是大家想像刚才举这个例子
像这个是ZELDA的例子
就是说当我去攀岩的时候
我同时要控制的AK点
可能要达到三个甚至四个以上
那么这个时候这个角色的行为会怎么样
那所以的话呢这个时候呢我就跟大家讲一句
I这个多控制点的IK呢
它最多n effect or
就是那个末端是那个效果器的时候
这个IK最大的难点就是
当我用刚才那些简单的算法
我去把一个点构造的话
那我因为我的共同那个节点发生变化的时候
其他的点再去够它的目标点的时候
就会把这个点偏来偏去
那事实上呢在CCD啊
还有那个fabric的话呢
也提出了一道叫多constrain的解决方法
在这里面我就不展开了
因为它我个人觉得还是比较high的
那么在行业里面最经典的一个解法是什么呢
叫做这个雅克比矩阵的解法
这个东西大家又看到了
又嗅到了我们104课程的久违的气息了
对吧
我我已经感到了这个这个不好意思
这个前方高能预警
但是呢我得跟大家讲
这是个这是个假假情报
First along
为什么呢
因为我们经过慎重的研究和决定
我们认为就是在动画这节课
我们要保持整个动画课程的轻松愉快
所以我们决定把非常复杂有趣的
这个亚克比矩阵的话呢
放到我们后面两节课讲讲那个物理系统的时候
跟大家去讲
但这里面就跟大家讲一下雅克比矩阵
一个最简单的概念
就是说实际上当我们一个长链条
你的这个每一个轴的旋转
它假设每个轴都有SA选
那个都是个旋转对吧
其实你当你这些这一堆旋转之后
实际上你的端点在空间就是一个坐标值
就是一个位置
那这个位置就是随着你的旋转一直在变的话
这个位置点一直在变
对不对
那我多个约束点其实就是多个位置点的问题
那这个呢你可以把就是角度想象成一个向量
比如说X对吧
然后呢把他们最后那些end point
就是你要控制的那些端点在空间上的位置
想象成是一个
就是关于X这个角度值的一个方程
那这个方程的话呢
它它它的它的它的自变量是个是个
是个是个向量了对吧
它的输出呢其实是一个三维空间的vector
这个听上去有点抽象了
有点高能了
然后呢它和目标点之间的这个距离
或者说啊或者是空间的位移吧
它也可以成为它的一个结果
那雅克比呢他就说你对于这样的一种方程组啊
空间上的高维方程组
其实你可以用它的这个梯度
就是说在任何一个当前的角度
就是这个这个就是当前摆的这个pose情况下
诶
你动那么一点点
他的这个微分
就是对你最终的点那个产生那个距离
那个那个微分呢
其实可以表达成一个它的趋向性的
也就是它的导数的这个矩阵
这个听上去是不是有点抽象了
所以今天这节课我就不展开了
但是呢其实它的核心思想是什么呢
就是说当我去优化一个
我从我这个长臂假设里面有三四根骨骼
我到这个点
我既然知道这个趋势的时候
我其实可以解这个矩阵
那我比如说我先把目标点设置的
离我的这个点非常的近
那我尝试我可以反向求出来
我每个角度要动作小德尔塔theta是多少
我让他离这个点再近一点
然后呢
我再去往前走一小步
我在一起求出每一个计算机的
走的小小的delta theta
我又再往前进一点
经过我一次次的构造这个矩阵
然后再反向求解这个矩阵
就求出了每一根轴的一点一点
1.1.1点的变化
最后A让他能hit到我的点
听上去是不是很简单对吧
但我知道我是在骗你们的
这个这个东西还真的是不简单
就是亚克比矩阵的话啊
求解起来还是挺复杂的
那今天的话呢
我就不跟同学们讲这么硬核的东西了
因为我说好了
要留给那个啊物理那一趴对吧
物理那一趴将充满了各种正能量
那所以的话呢就是说大家最简单的一个理解
就是说
用雅克比矩阵方法去优化这个多目标点的话
它实际上是一个逐渐逼近的过程
就是每一次我从当前的端点
向我的目标点靠近那么一小步
然后呢求解一个每个joint应该转的这个角度数
然后呢这个时候当然这个其实是有误差的
诶
我转完之后我再算出我真实的位置
然后呢再去构造一个亚克比矩阵
然后再去求解
所以这个呢其实是啊
我们的这个游戏引擎行业的话
在过去吧一个非常标准的一个就是多joint
然后呢多约束的一个IK的一个解法
但实话实说他的计算机非常的复杂
而且呢也比较费
所以有很多的工作就是在讲
怎么样能快速的去解求解这个雅克比矩阵
实际上的话呢在行业里面
我们IK的东西啊用的也还是非常多
包括像现在就是这个physics space的这个方法
就基于物理的IK的方法
因为其实AK有的时候它不是一个纯的
一个叫焦点约束的问题
它实际上还有它的物理的这个合理性
包括基于position based的dynamics
这个是啊
像现在前沿的一些引擎也在用的一个方法
包括就是说啊基于这个PPT的这个full body的
这个这个这样的一个IK
也是现在大家比较hot的一些方法
所以呢我现在看
我们现在看的就是你KB矩阵的话
是一个经典解法
但是呢physics based
包括属于position based的方法的话呢
也在越来越热
所以其实啊
IK实际上是一个非常难的一个问题
到现在为止
IK还是有很多的挑战
比如说我解完一个IKIK
它会假设你的骨骼是纯抽象的
它没有空间的体积
但是当我给他蒙上蒙皮的时候
这些IK解出来的结果会自我穿插
自我交叠
这个问题其实还是比较难解决
还有呢就是说哎我们的IK
很多时候都是说我有个约束点对吧
但是你想想看
就是你刚才这个这个这个乐队的例子
我前面的约束还没有到我的面前
但是呢人实际上是有这个perception
我们身上是有这个预知的
所以你会早早地弯下腰
让自己能够穿过去
其实这件事情说起来很简单啊
但是在游戏里面做起来其实并不简单
如果你现在回想一下
我们看过很多3A大作吧
你看到那个角色跟环境诶
能够很聪明的做出
这样或者那样的一个互动的话
实际上都是我们的designer
老老早在那边放了很多的这种就是检测题
说哦你要靠近一个洞啊
这个时候我就让这个角色很聪明的知道怎么去
这个就是说弯下腰
当然我这个检测器可以自动生成
但是呢真的能够就是perception这个environment
然后呢能够非常像human like的
去控制我的身体的姿态
这件事情其实也是个非常难的一个问题
那么还有就是更自然的这个人类的这个行为学
比如说IK解说啊
他有个东西
他不管他不管什么东西
他不管平衡的问题
这是我们做出的每一个动作
实际上它都是重心是要平衡的
比如说哪个角是支撑脚对吧
你的重心在哪里
都要符合这个动力学的规律
而这一点
在目前刚才我讲的所有的IK算法里面
都不会去解决
这就是为什么现在游戏里面很多的IK
看上去就不是那么自然的一个原因
所以其实IK呢是一个
非常现在还在快速演进的这样的一个研究领域
就是我们课程组找了一个资料
发现其实在过去的十几年里面
IK方面的文章是越来越多
特别是最近的这10年
为什么最近10年IK的算法大爆发呢
因为就是说随着我们的3A游戏
要求越来越高的话
那我们希望这个角色更加的就是environment advice
就是以前的这个游戏啊
角色就是自说自话
我放出一个大招对吧
我这个不管我这一拳塞到墙里面了
还是打穿到别人的肚子里面了
都没关系
反正就是这个我的意思就到了
但是现在的3A游戏
包括我们一些高端的游戏产品的话
我们非常在意这个角色看上去是不是真实可信
所以呢IK的话呢
就今天我觉得上完这个104的课程
同学
我觉得take away两件事情就是关于IK这1part
第一大家知道了三个比较经典的算法
一个是CCD
一个是这个就是fabric
还有一个就是说知道有个有个数学工具
叫做夹克比矩阵就可以了
但CCD和fabric的话
我希望大家能够理解透
然后呢你平时做一个简单游戏的话呢
你用TOBAK基本上可以了
但是呢如果你自己的数学基础特别的好
而且对这件事情特别感兴趣
这个强烈推荐
IK是一个非常有意思的一个研究方向
而且你研究到后来
你会发现你和这个人工智能
和这个就是说和这个这个一些perception
一些行为关系还是蛮大的
在这一点上的话
我我是不敢妄称专家的
因为我觉得这里面很多团队做的非常的好
所以其实IK为什么这么重要呢
因为在一个实战性的游戏引擎里面
IK会实实在在的改变动画的pipeline
大家还记得上一节课
我们讲了这个动画的pipeline对吧
还是比较简单
就是A我把动画的这个CLIPSE拿到之后
我们导成各种各样的这个这个pose对吧
再把pose再一起去blend
但是呢你有了IK之后的话呢
你就要先把这个blend pose啊
把它反向算到这个模型坐标系
你还要把它反向算什么呢
算到世界坐标系
这个时候我要跟在这个世界
就是在世界坐标系里面
也就是在我的环境里面的各个约束在一起
去反向的去结算
我的AK就是每根骨骼该怎么去调整
然后根据这个IK的话呢
我再去调整我要提交给我的渲染器的动画
所以这个过程呢在动画开发里面我们叫做什么
叫做post process对吧
这个这个地方的后处理
和我们在渲染的一节课的后处理
讲的不是一个概念
但是呢这个动画系统process process
很多时候指的就是IK
就是说让我的动画符合
对于环境的各种各样的约束
所以这有了这一趴之后
才是一个基本完整的一个动画的PAPI
讲到这儿的话
我们就讲一点比较轻松的吧
就大家最喜闻乐见的是什么
就是这个可爱的小姐姐
各种各样非常可爱的游戏里面的角色
那么一个角色你让人觉得可爱的话呢
这也是我们动画系统干的很重要的活
叫做表情动画对吧
那这里面的话这个这个对吧
跳票了的游戏总是要跟大家道个歉吧
连道歉都可以道歉的
这么萌
我就选择了原谅
那么其实这里面的话
这个角色之所以让大家这么这么感动
这么有感觉的话
就是他的整个表情
这个人物的表面做的非常的细腻
那表情的话怎么做呢
其实先讲一个非常学院派的概念
就是人的表情是怎么来的
是他下面有很多很多跟肌肉
我记得如果没没记错的话
应该是40多个肌肉吧
哦对我上面写了43个肌肉
然后的话呢他有的是横向的
有的是纵向的
有的是这个这个这个这个放缩的这种肌肉
能够形成人的表情
其实人人类的飞手在进化学上是有很多讨论的
就是说整个动物界好像只有人类
进化出如此丰富
如此细腻的表现系统
甚至我们认为就是人类社会
之所以能进化出这种高级文明
就是因为我们这种表情
帮助了我们在族群内部的沟通
包括为什么你们要养宠物
就是其实大部分动物是读不懂人类的表情的
而我们的狗跟着人类上万年
他是少有的几个能够看得懂人类的表情的
这个生物的物种
因为人类的表情是非常非常subtle的
所以说你们家的狗你一定要真实
因为它是真的会对你察言观色的
就是表情
为什么他这么难呢
就这里面就举个例子
就这你们是一个演员的表演
你发现没有
她从嫌弃你到喜欢你
就是有点暧昧
他几乎没有明显的动他的五官
但是我相信我们所有的同学
仔细看这个视频的时候
你能看出他微表情的变化对吧
我们我们叫做subtle和subtle的这种expression
那这就是表情特别难以做的一个东西
就是过去在早年我们在做计算机的这个
人物角色的时候啊
实际上那个只能做简单的角色
就开口张口说话
然后呢还有这个大笑哭对吧
都非常的浮夸
但是你看现代的游戏引擎
它就越做越细腻
越做越真实
这其实就在追求这样的一种真实度
因为它的精度要求是非常非常高的
那怎么去表达这个表情呢
那这个不得不感谢我们的电影行业
其实在很久以前
电影行业就引入了一个叫做就是那个FA cs
这个系统就是那个facial action coding system
它把人类常用的表情归纳成了46种
就是标准的叫action unit
这就是叫叫这表情单元
然后呢
他认为就是你的表情就可以用
46种表情单元就可以表达出来
这件事情真的是做的非常的了不起
这一点我不得不说
就是说啊就是他那种怎么说呢
就是电影行业的这些老哥
是有非常好的这种理工科的基础
他用这种很工科的方法
去把这么一个文科的事情给他给就定量化了
就像我上次在讲post process的时候
我在讲这个电影行业一出来
我们的所有的这个滤镜都瞬间这个失色了
这电影工业的同学说
我我来教你们做表情的时候
我们游戏行业的人基本上说大哥
你告诉我怎么做
你说怎么做我就怎么做
你说的永远是对的
确实是这样
因为他们对这种真速度的这种要求啊
是远远高于我们的游戏行业
特别是大家看了最近几年奥斯卡电影的话
你会发现就是这种虚拟拍摄
虚拟角色的这个水平是越来越高
所以他们是走在这个行业真正的前沿
那这里面的话呢就是说其实这些AU的话呢
可以用某种方式可以进行组合
举个例子
比如这里面这个男人的眉毛诶
皱起来他是一个AU对吧
眼睛睁大又是一个AU
然后呢你可以表达一个东西
就是眉毛那个这个这个放下来
然后呢眼睛真大
这个其实动作我自己试过一次
我发现还是有点难的
后来我才知道
其实这些专业的演员啊
实际上他的表情肌是要经过专门的训练的
反正我是做不到
但是呢其实我们需要理解一个概念
就是说哎这些就是这个表情动画单元
实际上可以像我们的这个函数一样
可以自由地组合组合出各种各样的表情
那你有这样的一个FS这样一个概念之后
实际上我们很多东西可以做了
这里面要不得不提到
就是其实这里面apple的话呢也做了很多的工作
他会发现就是说嗯他把这么多的AU啊
归他觉得46个太多了
他把它总结成了我们实用的28个
然后呢28个最核心的AU
然后呢其中他发现有23个是对称的
比如说我的眼睛闭和开对吧
左眼闭单眼皮的闭合开
右眼皮的闭合开
你只要存一个就可以了
然后呢你两个同时开的
就是眼睛睁开两个同时闭
就两个镜避开
也可以睁一个闭一个对吧
所以因为人体的大量的表现
其它都是这个对称的
所以呢在我们的行业里面
我们一般用28个这个COACTIONAU就好了
那这个的话呢
也是感谢apple给我们做了这样的一个总结
那有了这个概念之后
其实就比较简单了
对不对
我们在上一节课讲过一个很重要的动画
叫什么叫vertex animmation对吧
顶点动画
每个顶点我存一个动画
那不很简单吗
我你不就说你不就是28个AU吗
我每个AU我想一个动画行不行
哎我这个时候这个角色
我这个嘴巴沾一嘴巴歪一下对吧
眼睛睁开了
这个表情
两个叠在一起
我就能形成我一个想要的表情
这个看上去是不是非常的简单
是的
这个是非常简单
但是呢这种简单的线性叠加会产生一个小问题
就是说如果我存的是每个顶点
在这个表情下的位置
那我对动画的叠加呢就是一个乐产生的结果
可能不是我想的
举个例子
我的第一个动画是这个人张大了嘴
眼睛真的很大
这个动画我第二个我想混合的表情是
他闭上眼睛是闭上眼睛张大嘴
你会发现你把这两个就是表情合到一起
做一个线性的加法的时候
你得到的这个角色呢是嘴巴是张开了的
但是他的眼睛呢是半半闭着的
这样的一个结果
为什么眼睛张开和眼睛闭中间差距不是半闭的
所以实际上当我去表达一个AU的时候
因为刚才那个图中
你会发现他一个AU都是在脸上的局部
做这样的处理
所以我们想要的结果是什么呢
我的嘴巴这个区域我要用你张嘴的这个动画
但是呢我眼睛这个地方的话呢
我是想用百分之百的用的是我闭眼的动画
所以呢我们在真实的存一个AU的时候
存的是什么呢
它的这个表情下
他那个区域相对于他的neutral face
就中性表情下的顶点的offset
这样的话我们就可以自由的把这些动画
就是合在一起
这个方法叫什么呢
就是我们的morptarget animation
所以其实大家如果看游戏啊
大部分的游戏表情的动画
都是用这个用这个技术去做的
那么这里面的话呢就比如像这个女性的角色
她的各种动画表情的话
其实就可以用做
那为什么大家会很奇怪
说我们为什么不用那个骨骼动画去做呢
其实国动画可以做
但国动画呢它有的时候他表达一个简单的
比如说眼睛皮皮张开啊
合并是可以的
但是呢你表达一个就嘴巴A往前嘟嘟嘴啊
收收嘴这种东西
其实骨骼动画表达起来就比较麻烦
而且也不自然
所以呢一些细腻的动画表现
其实主要用的就是MORPTARGETANIMMATION
其实大家如果学完了前面的渲染
理解了什么叫做project animation的话
实际上理解这个表情动画的这个表达方式的话
或者绘制方式的话就非常的简单
但是呢这个东西的话
实际上就像在我们的游戏引擎实战中啊
它不会完全只用MORPTANANIMMATION
实际上在现在的这个游戏里面的话
我们还是会用骨骼做大量的这个动画的
这个表情
动画的表演
为什么呢
谷歌它有很多好处
举个例子
比如说角色的眼球对吧
你用MF就很难做
眼球很灵动啊
它一会儿左一会儿右
对不对
这肯定就是得用骨骼去做
包括刚才我提到了一些比较大的这个动作啊
就是比如嘴巴张开啊
这些东西的话也很有用
其实还有个更有用的东西是什么呢
就是大家特别喜欢的那个捏脸对吧
我对我把一个我给你一张标准的脸
你列出一个你想要的脸
其实这里面既有这个莫夫的这个功劳
又有这个骨骼的功劳
但这里面的话呢这个模型就会比较复杂了
而且这个东西的话呢
它其实它不是一个引擎技术的问题
它实际上是我们的我们的艺术家同学他有多强
所以这个东西在一个3A级游戏里面
特别是像我们经常玩的那种韩式游戏里面
他光一个捏脸系统
可能是一个团队做3年以上
所以我们经常讲的恋恋本身就是一个游戏
因为这个实话实说
我们要对这件事情表表达敬畏
因为它的复杂度
它的工作量真的就在那个地方
你要花大量的时间去精细的调
那个就是表皮下的骨骼
同时的话呢要做大量的他的这个MF的这个target
这样的animation
让这个角色的话有各种各样的这个外形
有各种各样的变化
而且动起来各种表情看上去很自然
那么其实呢这里面再顺便给大家提一下
就是说在引擎中啊
我们表达表情不只是用这个几何表达
其实如果你做一个2D的这个动画
Texture
是不是也能表达这个角色的各种各样的动画
大家还记得上节课我们讲的那个
就是live two d的方法吗
其实你想如果把live two d变成一张texture的话
那么它的结果变成texture
把它apply到一个几何上
是不是也能表现各种活灵活现的角色的效果
所以这其实对于那种很多的卡通化渲染的
游戏来讲的话
我觉得他绝对比那个move的
就move target animation和那个骨骼动画更实用
而且效率更高
那么最后一个呢
这个就是纯属于这种科研性质了
就是说实际上现在还有一批人在研究
非常前沿的
就是真正的把那个43块肌肉动起来
来表达一个人
这里面的话他要非常细腻的定义
说诶我的骨骼的运动
骨骼上面的肌肉的运动
肌肉在牵动我皮肤的运动
这件事情的话呢
现在有些初步的结果
但是目前在游戏引擎中看的比较少
更多的可能是在影视行业里面
大家在用
那么但是它的结果确实非常的漂亮
而且也许随着未来
我们的计算机的算力足够强的话
我们不用再用这么复杂的这个这个move
Target animmation
因为MOTANMATION虽然算法非常简单啊
但是它的数据存储量是很大的
另外一个的话呢就是说他的那个就是计算量
随着我的表面上的这个细节越来越多的话
它也会越来越这个复杂
所以说这个呢
也许未来会成为我们更高精度的角色的表达
所以fish mation的话实际上是一个非常前沿领域
因为简单做做很简单
但是你真的要做的非常好的话
非常挑战
比如说像unreal的matter human
我认为这是目前整个行业的这个天花板
也就是他对这个角色很多细腻的微表情的表达
包括你看他眼珠
包括他的整个这个角色的这种自然态和真实态
就大家想一下
如果要做得这么好
这么自然的话
它可能不仅仅是我怎么去用MORPTARGET
animation和骨骼动画来表达了
其实还包括什么呢
你怎么去capture
怎么去采集到这个东西
也就是说它不像我们的动作动作
可以在身上绑几个绑点
我就可以采集对吧
它实际上现在飞驰的采集呢是一个相机对着你
但相机对着你拍到的是一帧帧的照片
我怎么从你的一帧帧的这个video中
能够decomposed
就是解构出你的表情
你是皱眉了
你是你你的这个颧骨这边动了一下
还是你脸上挤出了一个诶小酒窝小笑纹
这个其实是非常非常挑战的一个技术
但是呢很很感谢我们这个行业
就是这个技术呢
目前也相对来讲有一些很好的基础
也有有些成熟
但是呢做到像这个质量的话
还是有很多的挑战
这就是今天我们简单讲一下
就是这个表情动画这一趴
那最后呢跟同学们讲一个
就是这个比较简单的东西了
就是也比较简单
就是说哎动画的这个重定向
Animmation targeting
它的核心的应用场景是什么呢
就是说实际上在我们做这个动画系统的时候
我们当然希望对于每一个角色
动画师都给我做很多很多动画
这个角色活灵活现
但实际上动画是做不到对吧
特别是当我们现在越来越多的依赖于motion
Capture
就动捕设备的时候
我不可能为不同的高低胖瘦的这个角色
都会重新录一套完整的动画
所以呢其实ANIMMATIONRETARGETING的话
就是说我把一个角色的动画诶
也能apply到另外一个身材比例不一样的
动画上面的话呢
这其实是一个刚需
所以呢那RETARGETING它核心的话
那个要解决的问题就是说我们采集一套动画
可以应用在各种各样的角色上面
那这里面首先呢我们定义它的
这个就是一个名词学terminology
就是说大家现在知道
就是这个这个以后你们出去跟人家讲说
我学过这个游戏引擎的话
就可以讲这些很专业的词汇了
比如说我的动画RETARGETING
首先你原始的采集那个动画的角色叫什么呢
叫source character
就是原角色
你要去apply动画到另外一个目标学生呢
我们叫做target character
那原角色上面那个原始的一个动画
比如说走啊跑跳诶
我们叫做source animation
那你apply到那个目标角色上了
你看到那个动画叫什么呢
叫target amation
听上去非常的高大上
但实际上就非常的简单和直觉对吧
你这个一个是数据源
一个是我的数据的目的地对吧
你角色就叫原角色对吧
动画就叫就叫原动画那一样的
反之亦然好这就是名词
因为这个名词定义好了
后面的和后面就好理解了
那实际上呢
其实当我去把这个原动画里面的这个角色
里面的这个这个动画apply到这个目标角色时候
比如说具体以以这里面这个例子
这个女的character
她个子身高
甚至姿态都和那个大怪物长得是不是不太一样
你看那大概我是不是有点口碑
但她个子很高对吧
那个那个女孩子长得比较直
那他这里的动画怎么去表达呢
其实很简单
我骨骼一根对一根对吧
那谷歌之间它是有位移的
对不对
比如说那个大怪物的那个那个那个那个脖子
这个地方可能是2米多高
那个女孩子可能只有1米4
1米5左右
但没关系
我们就认为他们还是一对应的
我去忽略他所有的这种位移项
那么另外一个的话呢
就是说当我这个动画在动的时候
这个女生比如说点个头
他向前把这个脖子
这个地方骨骼往前掰了30度
但是他一开始的角度是垂直的对吧
但是大怪物呢他那个脖子呢
大怪物可能有点有点驼背
他一开始这个脖子是想向前倾了
比如说15度
那这个动画怎么去LY呢
这个时候动画我们去LY的时候是apply
它相对于原始的bounding pose的旋转的位移
这个是个很小的细节
但这个细节非常的重要
就是否则的话
你本来是一个站在那儿口着背的这个怪物
但是的话驮着背的怪物
当你去被RETARGETING
一个A站的站姿很笔直的一个女孩子的这个
比如说走路动画的时候
你会发现在播放这个动画的时候
那个大概我一下子就站直了
所以呢其实我们传递过去的是动画的
这个相对的这个旋转
相对的放缩和相对的位移
相对于它的Bunny pose
而不是绝对的就是local space旋转
这是个小细节
当然了就是我们在动画存储的时候
很多时候我们存的就是相对的旋转
和这个scale和位移
所以的话呢这个问题不大
但是呢这个如果根据你的存储模式吧
如果你存的是logo space里面绝对的这个旋转的话
这个地方要做个小小的变化
就是说如果这个大胳膊一开始是驼背的时候
播放他的动画的时候
我们希望它还是驼背的
要保持他那个整个的姿态
因为你们如果真实的跟artist在一起合作的时候
你会发现他对这个这个角色一开始的这种姿态
比如说是耸肩的
是驼背的
其实就是这个角色本身的这个定义好
那有了这样一个东西之后呢
其实就比较简单了
就是我们把所有的这个旋转动画诶
把它的旋转动画的对应
依次的apply到对应的骨骼上去
这个角色就能动起来
那么如果这个角色呢他有这种translation
就是平移动画的话呢
那我们怎么办呢
我们把它所有波及到这个骨骼啊
把它的相对长度这个考虑进去
然后呢按等比例的去放松
这个讲起来有点简单
但实际做起来有点复杂
但是我会更详细的解释
那么放缩也是一样的
放缩就是直接等比例放过去就拉倒了
那基本上你能得到一个A
有点意思的这样的一个角色的动画
那这里面特别容易出问题的是什么呢
就是这个角色的两只腿
因为你看啊那个就是每一个角色
他的这个大腿小腿的比例身高都不一样
你强行的把这个动画放出去之后
你会发现这个角色大概率他双脚是浮空的
最简单的做法是什么呢
就是A我通过这个角色的腰线连到地面
就知道这个角色身高
那这样的话当我去播放这个位移动画的时候
我播放完之后
我会把这个角色按照他的等比例算它的位移
比如说这个大怪物的在这个腰线这个地方的话
可能它离地面是一米对吧
当然那个那个那个女生那个角色腰线的离地面
可能比如说0.8米
那我就会相应的把这个位移的话往上提一下
这个时候能缓解一下这个角色的双脚离离离离
那个离空的问题
同时的话呢
如果你这个角色是在走
我们经常会把这个位移呀
会也存在这个off
作为一个offset的曲线存在这个动画中
那我们希望这个角色走的速度
跟他他的腰眼离地的高度成正比
也就是说假设这个巨大怪兽他的腰离地是一米
那个那个女生离地高度是0.8米的话
那那个大怪兽播放同样动画的时候
它的移动速度也要快一点点
否则的话你会觉得两只脚在地上
那个凭空滑滑步脚哎
那个foot skating
我讲过那个脚在地上滑步
就像你滑冰一样的脚在那滑
但是人没有往前走对吧
或者说人走路太快跟脚滑的不一致
这个是特别明显的一种
我们叫做artifacts
但是实际上呢对于大部分的时候
我们会发现
如果两个角色体型差的很多的时候
这种问题也不能被解决
为什么呢
因为这里面举个例子
这两个角色诶
他的这三它的高度都是一样
这左边的最左边的是它source啊
右边的是两个两个target
你发现两个target的跟那个左边的source的腰部
腰部的高度都是一样的
但是呢他的大腿关节的长短不一样的时候
当你播放一个A这个角色
蹲在那儿的动画的时候
你发现没有诶
这两个target一个是小腿太长
直接钻地而出
一个小腿太短
直接悬空了
所以呢这个时候
实际上我们要是真的做RETARGETING的时候
我们实实际上是要有一些IK的
就是说要把他的脚锁死在地上
这个时候你看上去才自然
所以其实REDARKLING啊要想做的好
还有很多的小细节才能让你做的比较好
但是呢有的时候这个问题也不用太怕
就是很多时候我们的RETARGETING呢
是采取离线的方法去做好
就比如说我游戏里就那些角色
我动画师做完了一个角色的动画的时候
其实我可以用离线的一些软件
包括一些更高级的算法
可以把这个他的这个动画
RETARGETING做得更加的自然和真实
那这里面的话他在讲一个更有意思的东西啊
就是说我们刚才讲的所有的
其实有个隐含的假设
就是说这个动画在不同角色之间传递
它的骨骼结
拓扑结构都是一样的
但事实上的话呢我们做各种各样的角色
它的骨骼真的是不一致的对吧
比如说以这里每个例子
就左边的这个最右边的这个这个这个角色
只有一根spin的这个骨骼
但是呢就是这个spin就是你的那个脊椎骨骼
但是呢中间那个角色
其实也就是我们最右边那个角色的话呢
它有三根骨骼
那他两个之间的动画
是不是可以可以互相传递的
这里面我就不展开了
因为对面的算法就会有非常多
我给大家讲一个最简单的方法吧
就是我们其实可以根根据骨骼名字去找对应
你会发现它们之间共同的骨骼很多
好在两个共同骨骼之间的话呢
我们可以定义一种类似的关系
这里面我讲一个就是大名鼎鼎的那个NVIDIA对吧
我们的那个就是那个那个那个N卡的
这个这个黄老仙这个这个NVNVIDIAOMINVERSE
这个这个很牛逼的这个系统
他怎么解决这个问题
他其实非常简单
就是把这两个名字相同的骨骼
中间的所有的骨骼看成一个映射
都映射到0~1
那好
那我实际上就可以在这个
比如说我的我的target是我的source是四跟五个
我的target只有三根五个
那我就把根据他们每个骨骼相对之间的长度
我可以规划到0~1之间的一个参数
对不对
那我比如说第一根骨骼
我觉得看它的参数
它很可能在就是source骨骼两个骨中间的一个点
那我就在那中间点找他那个位置
然后呢我就把那个骨骼这个点诶插上去
然后呢我再去插到第二个点
再插地上
你发现没有
就是说他虽然每根骨骼并不会严格的
和那个source的骨骼完全的一致
但是它大体上也呈现出了这个形状对吧
这个算法其实是非常的符合直觉和简单的
但是呢效果来讲的话
我觉得做的还是不错的
大家去看一下啊
就是这是那个ominous里面
这个RETARGETING的一个结果
我个人觉得还是非常expressive
因为我们知道就是你录这样的一个动画
其实陌生captain还是很麻烦的
我真的
如果把这个动画在这么多
大大小小的角色上再做一遍的话
其实挺难的
当然能做的这么好的话
我怀疑可能不止这么一个简单的算法
你可能还是需要有一些比如说啊DEPING的算法
或者一些更human behavior的这个natural的一些处理
让这些角色看上去更自然一点
不过呢RETARGETING呢其实还是有很多挑战的
就跟刚才IK一样
如果你真的想做的话
其实RETARGETING也是一个非常hot的一个research的领域
那这里面有很多问题很难解决
比如说角色的自穿插问题对吧
因为我们刚才就跟就跟刚才AK一样
就是我所有的计算都是假设一个抽象的
没有空间体积的这样的一个骨骼
那当我一个瘦瘦的女生的一个动作
我去apply一个胖胖的角色上的时候
他觉那个角色自身的手会穿出我自己的身体
你看这个图上展示的很清楚
还有就是其实很多动作呢它是有寓意的
比如说鼓掌对吧
那鼓掌的时候
我如果这两个角色的肩宽不一样的时候
实际上RETK完之后
这个手它就合不起来了对吧
那还有就是说也是更难的
就是RETARGETING完之后
其实我比如像有些比如像走跑跳
或者说哎我去尝试去购一个东西的时候
他的身体是要追求一种平衡感的对吧
其实还有一种符合动力学的自然感的东西
那你在作为TURKETING的时候
如何能保证这件事情
其实这就是RETARGETING的话
那现在一些比较hot的研究问题
但是呢如果你的角色之间相差
没有那么那么大的时候
其实很多时候return的结果是可以接受的
所以这也是啊这个技术啊
在游戏引擎里面比较有用的一个啊
比较难的一个东西
但是这个技术其实是非常的有用
因为当我们去做一个大型游戏
大型产品的时候啊
你一定要有这样的一个技术
这样呢我们动画师才不会反复的做大量的动画
会这样会累死他们
那其实呢这种RETARGETING啊
不止在这个skeleton动画骨骼动画上面
其实我们在前面讲到这个move target animation呢
实际上他也有RETARGET的问题
为什么呢
因为其实举个简单的例子是
我们在做人脸的时候
我们一般会把人脸的top全部一致化对吧
我会表达各种各样的人脸
那么在捏脸的时候
你通过骨骼一变动就跟整个脸都不一样了
但是这个时候我做的这个表情动画
可能是基于一张标准脸做出来的
当这个脸发生变化的时候
动画我要保持它的一致
实际上呢因为在前面讲的这些动画
它本身呢是通过这个就是说顶点的
相对有一俱存的
很多时候你会发现APOLLY的结果还可以
但是呢只有一种情况会大家要小心
就是说还是跟刚才鼓掌一样的
就是有些动作它是有寓意的
比如说眼睛闭上这个动作
当这个角色他的眼睛做得大了那么一点点的话
那你原来那个你的animation
就是你你的morptarget animation
他是眼睛可以闭上了
这个时候他的眼睛其实是闭不上的
所以你要处理这样的
也包括嘴巴也是一样的
对不对
我们的嘴巴张开
就说这个人嘴巴很紧张
闭起来
但这也是个约束
所以的话呢这个时候呢
我们会加入一些额外的约束点
说这个动画里面
我希望这些顶点它是一定要重合到一起去的
那么像这里面我们就上眼睑和下眼睑
我们会加一些约束点
那这个做法其实呢就今天不展开
其实也是比较简单
就是我先apply动画完之后诶
我发现这些点控制点没有重合
我强行的把这些点拉的重合起来
然后用一个简单的拉普拉斯算子
拉普拉斯算子
你可以理解成
就是我去模拟一个这个像那个橡皮表面对吧
你拉几个点诶
其他的那个点就跟着他也有一点弹性
一样的被他拉上来了
然后呢这样的话我整个这个眼睛就能闭得起来
所以这个当我们去做这个就是animation retargeting
Fish
ANIMMATIONRETARGETING的时候呢
这也是一个非常重要
大家需要考虑的东西
但具体的算法呢其实不难
大家可以查到他的资料
所以讲到这1part的话
我们的动画基本上就全部讲完了
就是说大家掌握了这门这两节课里面讲的
所有东西的话
我们基本上就可以做一个完整的这个动画系统
那么大家在在这节课里面
我们这个我们这节课是
既然叫做高级动画系统嘛
大家能够这个学到的东西是什么呢
第一个呢我们我们理解就是说blending animation
blending实际上是一个非常重要的一个系统
它实际上就是说连接了我们的game play
和我们的动画系统
也就是说我们通过game play去control我的这个动画
布莱尼系统
无论你是这个啊动画状态机
还是一个这个blender treat对吧
你都是有很多信号控制我
然后呢我能混合出各种你想要的动作
所以这是一个FK的
就是forward condemics的一个核心系统
也就是我们基本的输出一个基础的角色的动作
然后接下来的话呢
因为我们这个角色是在环境中
跟环境有各种互动
那我们所以需要inverse indemix
就是说给这个角色再加入环境的反向约束
让这个角色跟环境的互动看上去更加的自然
而我们用这种骨骼
再加上这个MORPTARGETMATION的方法诶
能实现一个更精细的角色的这个表情
的这个表达ANIMMATION
那这样我一个角色身体的动作也有了
脸上的动作也有了
那我们就有他的全套了
对不对
然后然后呢就是最后一点呢
就是说哎当我们游戏中的角色的外形
无论他的长相还是他的身高体重都会有变化
我们通过RETARGETING让一有限的动画资源
能够在各种各样的角色上都能用得起来
因为这个东西当我们比如说你去做一个广场
这上面可能有几千甚至上万的
那上万可能太多了
几百上千的这种NPC几百个是很常见的
那你希望他们的高矮胖瘦都不太一样对吧
但是你让他们都要走来走去
这个时候你一定要用RETARGETING这个技术的
那么所以的话RETARGETING
就是说相当于我的能量放大器
把我的这个动画的这个能能力
放到了多种多样的这样的一个游戏的角色里面
所以这就是我们的啊
一套基本完整的一个高级的动画系统
有了这样一套系统的话
你基本上就能做一个
看上去很像那么回事的一个游戏了
当然了
就是很多事情都是这样的
就是入门容易精通难
其实这里面的每一个点
比如像动画树也好
如果大家有兴趣的话
你会发现这里面的水很深
就是你们有很多很多的概念
就是你需要去理解
需要很久
结合你的产品
IK刚才我也讲了
就是研究起来是非常的辛苦对吧
有大量的数学
我今天还没有抛出我那个最高能的雅克比矩阵
大家同学们等着我下节课争取把它抛出来
然后呢还有就是表情动画
表情动画还好
不是很难
但是呢它的素材做起来是比较辛苦的
那么还有就是说RETARGETING
RETARGETING的话呢
啊我认为是不是那么难
但是你要想做得好
其实是非常难的一个东西
好这就是我们动画系统的全部
O那终于我们把我们的两节的游戏引擎
动画系统
这课讲完了
哎呀我终于又卸下了一个很大的报复
我现在每讲完一个系统
我感觉我就如释重负啊
讲完rendering
我就再也不看rendering了
我好像从此以后不要再做这个这个SHADER了
那么讲完ANIMMATION
我从此我再也不讲ANIMMATION了
累死了
那最后呢收官一下
跟同学们轻松一下
就跟他跟大家汇报一下
就是我们的小引擎
那么小引擎的话
就像咱们在前面跟大家讲的
就是说非常感谢社区的同学们给我们的反馈
然后呢
我们这边的话
也在积极的对小引擎进行一个REFACTORY
就是说因为我们希望把它改的真的大家方便
大家去理解去用
所以呢在明天我们可能会上传一个新的版本
就是这一次呢我们主要把关卡
还有那个g o component系统重新把它重构一遍
包括editor和这个引擎的RUNTIME的分层
我们觉得之前设计的不够好
我们把它清的再好一点
所以这段时间的话我们是自己看那些代码
其实一边备课嘛
但是呃我们会看代码的时候
会现在已经越来越能理解就是大家的视角了
就是会觉得哦
我们之前的有些架构有点想当然了
就是确实是你觉得他专业吧
他也不够专业
你说他这个清晰吧
它又不够清晰
其实我们自己还蛮自责的
所以的话呢我们就是大概会分成两三次左右
就对小引擎进行这种reflection
然后呢我们逐步的放出来
所以争取在明天的话呢
我们放出它一个新的版本
这次主要是会把关卡机O系统
还有component系统进行一次refection
而且不会把这个editor和引擎分的更清楚一点
同时的话呢还有同学们很多的bug
我们也修掉了
这里面比如说那个显卡之间
几个显卡之间打架的问题啊
包括一些就是挖坑的一些问题
我们都把它修掉
还做了一些简单的这个优化
所以的话也特别感谢就是我们社区
你们的小伙伴在GITHUB上对我们的反馈和支持
我们也非常希望小引擎能和大家一起
这个往前走
那么我们更加要珍惜这个plot这个这个名字
因为啊我们的名字征集的活动
现在也差不多已经接近尾声了
我们到时候会跟大家一起
在这个200多个名字中选出我们最喜欢的名字
去命名我们的小引擎
好的那到今天到这里的话
我们今天的课程基本上就结束了
再次感谢我们的社区的小伙伴们
还有我们的课程组的小伙伴们
其实虽然我今天站在这讲
但是大部分的工作都是我们课程组的小伙伴们
他们做完了
他们真的很辛苦
就是说这些课件的准备
包括小引擎的迭代
还有是同学们的很多的作业互动
都是我们的小伙伴们一起就是弄完的
所以我有时候挺不好意思
我觉得事情都是大家做了
结果我在这站在这儿了
所以同学们如果要感谢的话
一定要多多感谢这些课程组的小伙伴们好
那今天的课程就到此结束了
同学们有没有什么问题啊
有个同学问我说有没有三维的blank space
这个问题问的我无言以对
为什么呢
确实呃我确实没看过三维的blank space
理论上应该是可以的
因为你其实可以加入更多的控制变量控制在
但实际上的话
在实际中好像没有看过三位的ban space
他其实我猜测的道理是这样的
就是说如果是二维的blank space
大家看到那个图啊
在一张图你看到那个点动来动去非常的直观
而且你加更多的CLIPSE的话呢
也知道往哪加
如果给你一个三维的这个blank space的话
你在三维空间加这一点的话
至少这个加起来就比较费劲一点对吧
大家如果有学过3D max的使用
就会知道你要花很久习惯那个旋转啊
标点啊就很头疼
但是如果你有真的三个控制变量差值的需求
怎么做呢
其实比较简单
就是说你做两个blank space
然后呢中间再加个LP的节点
就是那个不缺你们loop的节点
把第三个维度变成loop节点的控制变量
其实呢在现代的现代的很多的动画树里面
都提供了那个叫做那个就是alias这种方法
就是你那个呃动那个2D的BSPACE呢
你可以把它就是通过alias的方法去重复两份
作为它的两个输入
然后进行插值
其实就可以了
所以我我我我认为三位的ban space的话
现在哦他应该不能重复
不需要用的A6S他两个bless输出
那个两个bless space应该不一样的
然后呢再通过一个lb就会形成三维的差值啊
面部表情
有同学问我说
面部表情是不是也是通过顶点动画做的
其实呢我今天课程讲的呢
就是说太倾向于那个MORPTARGETANIMMATION了
其实面部表情我认为至少我个人的经验是一半
一半就是骨骼动画
你不能忽略它
其实骨骼动画还是很重要的
但是呢more for target
是最后就是我认为画龙点睛的那一趴
但实际上呢大家可能会注意不到
做面部表情的时候
有的时候这个你的法向贴图
也是你表面上那个贴图的变化
比如说我有的我们有时候做表情的时候
你不是几何变了
而是你表面的那个皱纹发生了变化
这个时候对你这个面部表情的影响也非常大
所以说我们想表现一个
非常活灵活现的一个角色
它是多系统共同作用的结果
就是说我很难讲哪个最重要
但是你如果想做一个好的这个fish expression的话
实际上这些比如说skeleton的动画
骨骼动画
这个这个MORPTARGETANIMMATION
就是基于蒙皮的这个MV的这个动画
再加上这种dynamic的这种
比如说bump map的这种texture啊
或者说甚至是一些材质的变化
实际上综合在一起
让你产生了一个非常真实的角色的感觉
这里面讲下去的话就非常的深了
实际上这方面的话
其实电影行业的同学们研究的是非常非常的深
好还有没问题
哇这个这个问题问的太挑战了
我被同学问到
说动画领域里面有没有什么最前沿的问题
其实啊实际上刚才在课程中已经讲的
比如像IK真的把IK写好非常难
因为IK最难的是啊
其实数数学上总是能解得出来
最难的是你这个解看上去非常像人
比如说我购一个东西的时候
我的腰部的扭转
腿部的动作的配合对吧
包括我手的动作看上去很自然
比如你够个很高的地方
如果这个人只是这样够的话
你会觉得这个动作很僵
但是如果你发现他的脚尖稍微垫了一下
你会觉得很自然
那这样的一个就是非常human like的东西
它就很难
那么动画系统里面的话
其实我们在高级课里面会讲
那个就是说那个就是说哎那个animation的这个
那个那个就就就就就那个就是基于那个matching的
这样的一个一个animation的这样的一个blending
对吧
这个现在也用的非常多
为什么呢
因为它的整个那个space里面space非常的大
我怎么去快速的searching
怎么用deep选择最好的解
这个其实也是一个比较前沿的方向
大家还有什么问题
OK好的
那今天差不多也是一个多小时了
差不多已经是还有15分钟
又是两个小时了
所以的话啊
今天我们要不先这样
非常谢谢大家
那个我们下周再见
下周就进入我们高能的games
104物理那一趴
好同学们下周见